[Music]
okay and just 12
minutes is
that
okay
okay I just want to say
[Music]
hello
hey
first he walk in
[Music]
the oh
really challenged comes
[Music]
to he's
not
how are
you I've gotten shorter I must be me
getting
know
that's so we have a
[Music]
panel
I
did
[Music]
never
people may actually decided to come
to so to do it
take yeah CU you're going require
setting all
right so um the first thing I want to do
is is welcome you my name is Robert post
I'm the dean of the of the law school
and you know I uh generally convene one
or two conferences a week I'm here to
give the official blessing of the school
and to say uh that as a uh as a matter
of school policy it's wonderful
conference welcome everyone and normally
I do that in my role but this conference
is actually different because uh this
one actually the welcome comes from my
heart I think this is an
amazing I think we have amazing people
here from the different disciplines of
Public Health and from medicine and from
public policy and we have before us a
set of problems which are exploding it's
plainly the case that there are um
metastasizing intersections between the
First Amendment on the one hand and
medical practice and Public Health on
the other and it's also the case that no
one knows how to understand these things
it's a matter of confusion all over the
map so that's a perfect occasion to get
together Marvel people like are in this
room and uh and to talk about it now
this conference is not merely um uh
sponsored by the law school but also by
the school of medicine and the School of
Public Health and I want to extend to
both of those schools a a a great thank
you and also to invite uh first the dean
of uh the school of medicine Bob alurn
to say a few words and then the dean of
the School of Public Health Paul clear
where's
call a few words thank you Robert so uh
I actually Robert's better than me at
the conferences you usually I agree to
do a conference like this and I don't
show
up for introductory comments are for
anything but I thought it was important
that I uh welcome you from the land of
Ebola and
uh and this actually all started out of
a conversation that I came I I think is
New York the second circuit yes yes when
the second circuit have a uh decision uh
limiting the power of the FDA to tell
pharmaceutical companies uh what they
could say and I found that fascinating
and I think we ended up in a
conversation which uh one conversation
led to the next and now you're all
trapped here for two days the um but I
the this is really interesting actually
this whole Ebola thing has been really
interesting you know because everybody
said well you know we said Hippa limits
us from telling you who the patient is
that's in Yale New Haven Hospital and
the reporters said well do they have
children and we said we can't tell you
they said what do you mean you can't
tell us we want to know if our children
are at risk and and so the issues are so
complicated and so I'm hoping after this
is over I'm going to understand them all
all
clear anyways uh welcome I'm sure this
is going to be a great conference and
thanks for coming thank
you
Paul I'm Paul CL the School of Public
heal just wanted to extend a warm
welcome uh I know we're all eager to get
this substance so I won't talk a long
time just to say our mission is to
improve health domestically and around
the world we do a lot of basic science
but when you really get down to what are
the issues how do we Implement things
how do we advance policy they really
require these complex interactions
between medicine
Public Health policy law regulation as
you look through the agenda today I
think it's just an incredibly exciting
relevant potentially impactful agenda so
I'm very very excited about it and if
you want to know anything about a Bowa
just contact me during the
break for those of you who don't know we
had some graduate students who come back
and might that and one of them was
hospitalized and we had a test yesterday
to see whether the person had a bullet
did not but it was touch and go for for
a while and we were very relieved by the
state of the world um there are some
other people to thank for this
conference um one of them is Jack Falcon
the head of is where's Jack Jack here
Jack thank you so much for all the help
and um I would say the indispensable
intellectual architect of all this was
Amy kinsky where's am thank
you and the person who actually
made it happen made the buses run on
time made the hotel reservations made
the room residence Val Valerie Belair
again you where's
Valerie she's not here but in
her um so uh um I would say the origins
of U of this um conference would have
been inconceivable 30 years ago the
impact of the First Amendment on either
public health or medical practice was
negligible um at that time and in my
experience of these subject matters what
what one what what has seen in the last
um several decades is with regard to
Medical Practice one has seen increasing
efforts to regulate abortion and to
regulate what doctors can and can't do
with abortion patients and a lot of that
went through the medium of speech so it
began to raise a lot of uh questions
about the First Amendment rights of
doctors who are giving quote unquote
informed consent to abortion patients
and that began to escalate into issues
now of guns and doctors or sexual
orientation change therapy and doctors
and now one is beginning to see the
practice of medicine understood in so
far as the doctor is speaking as a free
speech issue um freedom of speech itself
begins in the United States as the
freedom of speech almost always almost
always understood in the political
context um but in 1976 our Supreme Court
uh holds in a case called Virginia
pharmacy that well speech is broader
than political cont EXT it also includes
say commercial and once that link is
made once speech is speech is speech as
an equation then of course anytime you
have written uh uh you have writings or
any times you have actual oral
communication then you have a potential
First Amendment problem but most First
Amendment Doctrine is crafted with a
specific situation in mind someone is
getting up in hide Park and they're
talking can they be censored because of
their Viewpoint because of their content
no but if you start to apply appara like
that to a doctor it suddenly begins to
look very strange and so um in the last
I think 3 years there have been at least
three different circuit opinions on the
regulation of the speech of doctors and
each one has taken a different uh
theoretical framework about how this
speech should be applied to um what
happens when a doctor is talking doctors
do a lot of talking uh and uh when on
the other hand with regard to Public
Health much of Public Health in the
United States refers to to um social
marketing it refers to um conditions on
the marketing of uh drugs or on making
of Health claims and public and all of
this is now directly under the rubric of
commercial speech and subject to
generalist courts uh reviewing Public
Health determinations on grounds of of
abstract doctrinal tests like the
Central Hudson test about which you'll
hear a lot more and so the question is
how do these tests inter that with the
real world of Public Health whose
reality with this Abola crisis uh we
should appreciate as a very grave and
very important situation as well as with
the reality of medical practice and the
best way to do that is to get together
people who are in these different
disciplines and we can talk to each
other to understand better the stakes of
the constitutionalization of Medical
Practice in public health these are very
serious issues it's not just playing
around with the words of the
Constitution as that that was nothing so
um that is the the point of this
conference that's why we've gathered
people from all of these different
disciplines together to think through
these problems we can better understand
how to craft the legal rules when we
better understand the actual Stakes that
are going on in public health in
medicine in public policy with regard to
these various areas and so um with that
we should get to assemble our first
panel
m
um welcome and um we have incredible
first panel set up for us which is going
to be talking about the first segment of
issues Food and Drug regulatory
questions um we're going to start that
panel kind of assemble ourselves and
we'll start right at o'clock so um you
know take a minute to do anything else
you need to do and we'll see you at
o'
yes here's so when this comes up there a
series
of
h
of commercial speech I was afraid
somebody I was afraid somebody might I
actually have a reprint which I forgot
to bring out but I still have a reprint
out wow an actual printed reprint an
actual printed reprint if you don't have
one for your library I I believe my
secretary keeps all those things so
yeah I think today I'm going to be more
skeptical you were pretty enthusiastic I
was pretty enthusiastic I'm not
sure well you know 40 nearly what 40
years of experience I think is is it 40
years now yeah and I think experence to
you the court has taken some twists and
turns that may have been unanticipated
at the time yeah um at least
I it certainly going the that direction
but are we better
off I you know it depends on my hat as a
regulator as a I don't think
we
I'm all set up because I can use Aaron's
computer Aaron
Aaron I
think you know it's hard to tell it's
hard to imagine a pre- pharmacy board
case it's hard to imagine that
existing no way we can read those it's
pretty hard to
read here you want how about if you how
about how
five okay that's
good and then when time's up go up the
semors sh we just come and put her
[Music]
hands um great so I think we might as
well get started we have a full room and
a lot of important issues um to to put
on the table so as I mentioned earlier
this panel is going to focus on Food and
Drug regulation and the intersection
between um free speech law and and Food
and Drug regulation um I think uh as as
Dean alurn mentioned the kind of
instigation of this panel probably
really goes back to a case that you'll
hear a great deal more about during the
panel in which the second circuit
concluded that the um the First
Amendment um in fact effectively
arguably invalidates a key part of the
Food and Drug regul uh uh uh Food and
Drug administration's regulatory
Authority um and prevents the agency
from uh prohibiting companies from
marketing drugs off label so we'll hear
um from a few of our speakers thoughts
about that but it is a very striking
decision because in effect suggests that
the First Amendment today um uh is in
cont lict with 60 years of a regulatory
structure that um has um been previously
thought to not present that certainly
the kind of acute First Amendment
problems that that it has thought to in
in that decision um so uh we'll talk
about that decision and the issues that
that raises and also um go beyond that
um for example uh issues that are being
raised um at the FTC which is tasked
with protecting consumers from among
other things misleading advertising um
when you um start to ask questions about
what constitutes misleading and you
think about how the First Amendment
might regulate what constitute what does
it mean to say a consumer is being
misled um very interesting questions
start to emerge about what kinds of
evidence you might need or what standard
you might need when a company is making
Health claims to say well that's false
or that's misleading and so we'll um uh
have David vadic in particular we'll
talk about that so um just to sort of
taste of I think some of the really
important issues that we'll have on the
panel today and I'll um mention uh just
before I start that we are live
streaming the event so in so far as
you're speaking speak into a microphone
and just be aware that that's happening
um and uh as I um now in my task as
moderator let me just say very briefly a
few things about who we have on the
panel um uh so we'll he first from um
Bill Schultz who's the general counsel
of the Department of Health and Human
Services before joining HHS bill was a
partner at Zuckerman sper also um had
important legal positions at doj and at
the FDA at the FDA he was Deputy
Commissioner for policy which means he
was the principal adviser to the
commission on lots of significant policy
issues and um regarding the management
development of regulations at the FDA he
also has a long history of um uh
thinking about the first amendment's
implications for the FDA argued in fact
on behalf of the FDA back in 2000
um a case called Washington Legal
Foundation versus Henny which was um
maybe uh a precursor to some of the
cases that we'll be talking about today
so he's an excellent person to lead us
off um after that we'll have Professor
Aaron kesselheim he's an associate
professor of medicine at Harvard Medical
School and a faculty member in the
division of pharmaco epidemiology and
pharmacoeconomics in the department of
medicine at Brigham and Women's Hospital
uh at Harvard Aaron leads the program on
regulation Therapeutics and law
uh which is an interdisciplinary
research core focusing on intersections
among prescription drugs medical devices
patient Health outcomes and Regulatory
practices in the law um his work is uh
supported among others by the Greenwall
faculty scholar in bioethics the Harvard
program in therapeutic science and the
FDA and Robert Wood Johnson um then
we'll have Professor David vadic who
teaches at Georgetown law school um in
many areas including First Amendment
litigation um he's also a co-director of
the institute for public representation
which is a clinical program Professor
vladic um recently returned to
Georgetown after serving for nearly four
years as the Director of the Federal
Trade commission's Bureau of Consumer
Protection and there he supervised the
bureau's more than 430 lawyers
investigators and staff um carrying out
the work of the FDC to protect consumers
from unfair deceptive or fraudulent
practices uh then we'll have Chief Judge
Alex kazinski who's been a circuit court
judge judge on the nth circuit since
1985 and chief judge now of the nth
circuit since 2007 um uh truly needs no
intellect no introduction I think um a
distinguished career before he was a
judge but also one of our I think most
cited and um uh recognized judge
intellectuals and um is particularly
been uh as somebody who teaches
intellectual property um very
influential on issues of intellectual
property and also free speech so we're
very lucky to have him to close off our
panel and um why don't we start off with
uh
Bill thank you Amy and um I want to
thank you and Dean PR for organizing
this conference I think it's it's a
terrifically important issue and one
that the people in this room can can
really contribute a lot to um I thought
the most useful use of my time would be
to talk about what interest is behind
this uh what interest Congress was is
trying to capture when it passed these
provisions of the federal Food Drug and
cosmetic act and what the interest is in
in terms of health care I don't think
it's an overstatement to say that what's
at stake here in terms of how the first
amendment is going to limit the FDA and
the government's ability to manage uh
claims on uh foods and drugs and and
other Medical Products um will'll have a
very significant effect on the future of
Healthcare in this country
um in addition to drugs and uh and Foods
it's going to also have an impact on the
fda's ability to regulate tobacco
products um I'm going to concentrate on
drugs I think that's where a lot of the
action has been but I I think the
principles that apply here apply
probably equally to medical devices the
issues raised in food and tobacco are
somewhat different but but they're
they're also somewhat analogous the
first thing that's important to
recognize is the applicable laws here
long predate the 1976 Virginia pharmacy
case and so they were passed at a time
when commercial free speech wasn't
recognized um and wasn't uh uh really
didn't need to be taken into account um
but it's it's instructive to go back and
look at the progress of
Regulation uh by Congress the the first
statute is 1906 the 1906 Food and Drugs
act um and in that statute there was no
pre-market review in a way it was the
kind of Regulation that some of the
courts are
suggesting uh is the alternative um
where the agency was given authority to
bring misbranding claims or false
labeling claims adulteration claims
against Food and Drug products but it it
did not review these products before
they went on the market um in
1937 uh 100 people died from a new
formulation of an old drug called Elixir
sulfanilamide and that caught congress's
attention and so they passed the
precursor to the modern uh Food Drug and
cosmetic act in 1938 which gave the
agency the authority to review drugs for
safety um but not efficacy so it really
was still not reviewing the claims it
was just looking at whether the product
was safe and we sort of went along with
that until the late
1950s uh when we had the thalidomide
tragedy uh where one of the most
successful drugs in history uh sold for
insomnia and a variety of other
conditions turns out caused birth
defects in children uh born to women who
had been taken the taking the drug this
shocked the medical profession it was
thought up until that time that there
was something called the placental
barrier there was a barrier between the
drugs that the mother took and and the
fetus but the lesson that was Learned
was that all drugs can be dangerous
because of unknown side effects and that
lesson is just as true today as it was
at that time and it led to a reasoning
by Congress if that's true then drugs
shouldn't be used unless they're first
CH shown to be effective because even if
we think they're safe there are things
that we may not know and that we're
going to learn later which led to the
Keith offer Amendments of
1962 uh where Congress said in order to
get a drug approved you have to not only
show that it was safe but the
manufacturer has to show that it was
effective and effective is is serious
effect efficacy is a serious exercise it
requires substantial evidence which was
defined this usually means two studies
uh statistically significant studies of
the drug one study for a device uh with
controls and so on and this is really
the beginning of
modern uh clinical research and and
modern standards for researching Medical
Products it's interesting to go back and
look at the uh legislative history um
because it it it shows that there was an
some attention given not to to showing
that the first use was effective but to
showing that sen report says on what
logical basis can one possibly argue
that the initial claim for a drug should
be supported by substantial evidence but
that successive claims should not be so
supported and Senator ke offer one of
the bills spon the Bill's really primary
sponsor in the Senate expressed the
concern that unless you required that
each PL each claim to be proven
effective you would have you could have
a situation where the manufacturer gets
a very narrow and maybe obscure claim
approved gets a drug on the market and
then can Market it for a very broad
claim very widely used claim without
without having to establish
efficacy um as part of these amendments
I think it's interesting Congress told
FDA to go back and look at the 4,000 or
so drugs that had been approved between
1938 and
1962 and determin whether they were
effective and there was a time period of
time given for the companies to gather
the evidence or do the tests but that
resulted uh in literally uh hundreds and
even thousands of drugs being taken off
the market because all these drugs were
being show sold um and efficacy could
not be
established now in terms of the case law
and the First Amendment analysis the
definition of drug actually turns out to
be very
important and the definition is an
article intended that's the key word
intended for use in the diagnosis cure
mitigation treatment or prevention of
disease so for example you can sell
apples for nourishment uh as a food and
there's no pre-market review or no
regulation but if you want to sell
apples to cure cancer that's
prohibited uh because you've now turned
that Apple into a drug and how do we
know that because we'll look at your
advertising and we can figure out from
your advertising and other ways too but
the primary way is promotion that the
intended use that you
intended uh that apple as a drug so side
by side you could have this exact same
Apple being sold as a food with no
pre-market review no regulation except a
fairly light regulation that FDA does as
foods but if you sell that exact same
product to cure cancer or for any of
these kinds of drug claims and you
advertise it then we will have evidence
that you intended it to be a drug and if
you didn't get it reviewed and approved
in advance that you that's illegal you
can you can be prosecuted for that uh
and it doesn't matter whether it's an
apple
or a new a new chemical
ingredient uh if it's so where the
intended use is for the treatment cure
uh mitigation or prevention of disease
uh then it's a
drug um this becomes very important when
we start talking about off Lael uses
these are uses that are not approved by
FDA um doctors are prescri are permitted
to prescribe drugs for these uses they
can be used for something um that isn't
approved by FDA but if the
manufacturer intends that the drug be
used for the off Lael use and the
manufacturer can be prosecuted under
under the statute and the P principal
evidence of intent the way we figure
that out is is how the drug has been
promoted and so um this theory has been
adopted U by the courts um there's a DC
circuit case Whitaker versus Thompson
which involved a dietary
supplement um being sold uh with the
drug claim and and the court said there
was
no first it didn't have to apply Central
Hudson or any of this First Amendment
analysis because the FDA was able to
successfully argue that the promotion
advert the promotional materials were
evidence of the intended use of the drug
and so it so the court said it didn't
raise a First Amendment claim
interestingly on a panel that uh uh
judge Roberts was on now just just chief
justice Roberts the case relied on a
Supreme Court case called Wisconsin
versus Mitchell which allowed spe speech
to be used as an indication of racial an
animus uh in in a
prosecution um so I want to mention um a
couple of other points I well let me
just say about coronia since that's
going to come up a lot here I'm sure um
this was the big ISS in crony if you
read the majority in descent the big
dispute was whether the case had been
prosecuted in a way that the prosecutor
had used the speech of the salesman as
evidence of intent and it would have
been a I think a much different case if
the defendant had been in the
manufacturer but in this case the
manufacturer pled out and what was in
the second circuit is the is the case
against the the the salesman and the and
the the big dispute was over over this
issue the majority sort
of didn't really decide whether this
intended use Theory Theory works but but
it said even if it does it it it wasn't
used here just a couple other points I
want to uh policy points I want to make
first of all there are huge safety
interests involved here that often are
not recognized fomite is not an an
outlier and in FDA testimony there are
there's a pretty good list of product s
um that were on the market used for off
label use um never tested and then when
they were tested uh it turned out there
were serious safety implications one was
Premarin widely used estrogen approved
for short-term use there was a theory
that for long-term use it was very
helpful uh in preventing uh coronary
artery disease when the study was
actually done it turned out the opposite
was the case and then increased use
increase the risk of vac vascular
disease but there's several others I
won't take the time to go through them
now um secondly um the prohibition
applies only to
manufacturers um it does not apply
obviously to academics or anybody else
who wants to talk about these uses it
also doesn't apply to researchers hired
by manufacturers and it doesn't even
apply to conferences
sponsored by manufacturers that are for
research purposes it applies in terms of
promotion uh thirdly um there is a very
important interest that Congress had in
uh preserving the incentive to do the
research in other words if you if you
allow companies to promote these
products uh without actually having to
prove whether they're effective or not
then they don't have the incentive to do
that research and we'll find out about
the first use but we'll never find out
about the Second Use which will really
impair uh the ability of
doctors um to practice medicine in an
effective way the final point is if you
want to get a sense of what would happen
if we sort of deregulate this area and
and allow companies to uh promote drugs
for off label uses just because of the
First Amendment all you have to do is
look at the market for dietary
supplements that is an unregulated
market and nobody has the slightest idea
which dietary supplements work and which
don't thank
[Applause]
you oh
okay
sorry all right well um thank you thank
you to Dean post and Amy and to uh um
for inviting me and for um putting me on
this distinguished panel um and I want
to uh follow up a little bit on some of
the themes that that uh Bill Schultz
mentioned um and talk about whether um
off Lael drug promotion is in accordance
with the First Amendment so I want to
start with a couple um uh statements out
front that are positive statements about
industry funded promotion of
pharmaceutical products first what what
can the industry offer in its promotion
it can offer in-depth knowledge about a
particular drug including reports about
recent trials nuances about some of the
details that are on the drugs label the
industry is a superb Communicator if
there's a message to get across they
have people they're you know the
marketing Specialists who who know how
to um who know how to communicate and to
know how to get their and know how to
get their message implemented and
finally they have substantial resources
to commit to the dissemination of
information um about drugs uh or
whatever product they're make they're
making but there is there's regulation
of of industry funded promotion and
these are the two basic um principles
around this this uh regulation first of
all the the the promotion is not allowed
to be deceptive or fraudulent lacking in
Fair balance or otherwise misleading
which is to say that it's not allowed to
contain favorable information from a
study that's not allowed to make the
conclusions to use statistical analyses
or techniques on a retrospective basis
or or if it fails to provide sufficient
emphasis for for information relating to
the side effects that's one major way
that that that industry funded promotion
is regulated the other is as uh is that
it has to relate to an FDA approved use
of a product which is to say that the
FDA has evaluated and given its
validation to to this um prescribe this
method of prescribing and the question
is is this second requirement
constitutional which comes up in the
case of zym or sodium oxybate with the
the um a medication that was approved by
the FDA um for a condition called
narcolepsy um with cataplex which is an
extremely rare condition um the active
ingredient here is actually the same
active ingredient used in GHB which is a
um a widely known um recreational drug
um but what the problem was is that the
manufacturer through its um
pharmaceutical reps promoted the drug
widely to Physicians for a number of
other conditions that the drug wasn't
tested for um and wasn't shown to work
for and indeed might have been very
dangerous for including insomnia chronic
pain Restless leg syndrome multiple
sclerosis and Parkinson's disease one of
these drug reps was uh um taped making
these conversations and he and the
manufacturer and a physician he was
working with were brought up um uh by
the government for illegal off label
promotion which led to the coronia case
um that we'll you are going to spend a
lot of time talking about over the next
couple days um in his defense um the so
the the manufacturer as Bill said the
manufacturer pleaded out um paid about
$27 million in finds coronia didn't
plead um and and made a defense invoking
the First Amendment and said that the
First Amendment does and his defense was
that the First Amendment does not permit
the government to prohibit and
criminalize a pharmaceutical
manufacturer's truthful and
non-misleading promotion of an FDA
approved drug Physicians for off label
use where such use is not itself illegal
and others are permitted to engage in
such
speech the the Circuit Court in
reviewing uh in reviewing this case used
the Central Hudson test um which I put
the four principles of of of here just
so that you uh we have them all and we
can and we so we can have a basis for
talking about them the first is whether
or not the speech concerns the legal
activity um and whether the speech is
misleading as a basis if if it is if it
concerns legal activity or is misleading
the speech is immediately thrown out and
this uh and the Central Hudson test
isn't applied if the speech uh um is not
found to be misleading then they then
they go through this three-part test
they ask first whether or not the
government's interest in restricting the
speech is substantial second whether the
regulation directly and materially
advances the government's interest and
third whether the regulation is narrowly
tailored to its
goal so how did the second circuit come
out in the coronia case well on the
first prong whether or not the speech is
illegal and misleading nobody argued
this this actually wasn't didn't come up
and it was kind of it was given as a as
a as in the case that the um various um
ridiculous uses that the drug was being
promoted for um were not uh inherently
false or misleading and so the the the
court skipped right over that and went
to um issue number two um is the
government's interest in restricting the
speech substantial and the court
actually held yes that the government's
interest is is substantial and they
found two substantial interests first
presing preserving the Food Drug
cosmetic acts approval process and
second reducing patients exposure to
unsafe drugs and then they asked whether
and then looking at the next PR do about
the material advancement of the
government's interest the Court held
that no in fact that the the regulation
doesn't Advance its interest because it
paternalistically interferes with the
free flow of information and the court
found it logically inconsistent to allow
an off Lael use by physicians on the one
hand but then on the other hand to
restrict its promotion uh by a
pharmaceutical company and then finally
they asked whether the regulation is
narrowly tailored to the goal as well
and uh the court again found no and the
court found instead that that there are
things that they could do short of
restricting manufacturers uh speech
about off Lael uses by requiring
disclaimers uh to be attached whenever a
manufacturer is talking about an off
Lael use by educating patients and
prescribers about the difference between
an off Lael use and an on-label use or
about um about what uh or about the the
the possible um evidence that is used to
support an on orof label claim that they
could cap the number of prescriptions a
prescriber could write or they could
Warn prescribers and manufacturers about
their malpractice risk if they prescribe
drugs off label um as if Physicians need
to be warned warned about their risk of
malpractice U but that's a different
issue so the main questions that I want
to discuss in in the last half of my
remarks are are these three what is the
government's interest in regulating off
Lael promotion and is it paternalistic
or logically inconsistent for the
government to do so what would be the
consequences of the lack of such
regulation um and what other
Alternatives exist so why do we regulate
industry promotion well first because
promotional statements strongly Drive
prescribing Behavior there's Decades of
research a strong consistent specific
independent association between
physician and prescribing and their
exposure to pharmaceutical
Representatives it's as I said in the
very first slide industry promotion is
extremely successful in moving in moving
prescribing practices and and there and
and in this context industry promotion
is permitted in the context of uses of a
drug for which the supporting evidence
behind that use has been extensively
reviewed by the FDA and I and I also
want to point out that determining
whether a drug is sa is safe and
effective for an intended use involves
dozens of FDA scientists pouring over
terabytes of data studies in animals
toxicologic evaluations clinical trials
this is how a drug ends up being
approved for the use it is approved for
so why is it that we allow off Lael
prescribing um as my as my mentor Jerry
aor likes to say um you know the FDA
approval process is very rigorous but
it's also very limited the FDA approval
process tells us how well a new
medication works when prescribed by an
atypical doctor treating a small sample
of volunteer patients that
underrepresents a key population in a
highly protocolized trial design that's
usually brief compares the new drug to a
placebo and may use a surrogate measure
rather than an actual clinical outcome
right so the you know the real life real
life prescribing is much messier than
this and you actually you need to
consider treatment options for
Associated conditions other patient
subpopulations it would be completely
impractical to um not allow Physicians
to take these other considerations into
account and to prescribe either slightly
or or in some cases quite uh quite a
distance away from the actual trials
that led to the fda's to the approval of
the FDA so that's why we that's why off
Lael prescribing is a necessary function
in in the in the marketplace yet it's
still problematic to allow promotion of
off-label uses there's a concern that
industry will bury physicians in an
avalanche of unbalanced and potentially
inaccurate information about the off
Lael use that these and these that this
information though not completely false
would just be unreliable because it's
based on a flawed study design or it
lacks the proper context um and that the
result would be real harm to patients
for from ineffective or dangerous
treatments promoted by manufacturers
with a financial interest in achieving
as broad a possible use of in their
products um unsubstantiated claims by
manufacturers about their medicines can
result in tragic Public Health
consequences and this isn't just a
theoretical concern there are dozens
andz dozens of examples of this
happening over the last uh the last
decades um in which this occurred you
know talk about the fizer case with
Geodon you know where they promoted
improperly conducted trials and
incorrectly presented the trials they
denied misidentified or minimized or
omitted information um or or the Lily
case where they used a reprint of a
study in 28 patients um taking Zyprexa
for 8 weeks to promote off Lael uses of
the drug despite its association with
mortality natur cor which is a drug
approved in the management of CHF in
inpatients the manufacturer promoted the
drug for for costly ambulatory infusions
for outpatients with stable CHF a use
that was curtailed when the drug was
found to be associated with mortality
and and the examples go on and on and on
there were over1 15 billion dollar worth
of civil and criminal settlements
related to these related to these uses
so are the limits on off label promotion
paternalistic or logically inconsistent
I would say no that there's it is not
paternalistic to recognize the obstacles
that prevent Physicians from making
sound prescribing decisions when it
comes to off Lael prescribing and that
there is misplaced judicial confidence
in Physicians and consumers ability to
sort through marketing claims it's just
not possible for Physicians to conduct
the same rigorous evaluations that the
FDA does even if such data are available
to them which they often are not and
it's not logically inconsistent to allow
off Lael prescribing uh uh and to
prohibit off-label promotion when off
Lael promotion is so often flawed so so
what happens in a postc coronial world
what are the consequences of lack of
Regulation well as Bill said you what
will happen is you'll get drugs approved
on the basis of the smallest indication
possible the manufacturer will then
conduct studies of variable quality
showing its utility for unapproved
indications that wouldn't meet current
FDA standards for scientific rigor many
of these studies would appear to support
claims of efficacy with those that met
marketing claims selected for emphasis
and the others ignor the result will be
a growth in non-evidence-based off-label
uses with predictable non negative
public health benefits it will reduce
manufacturers incentives to conduct
well-controlled that would meet the FDA
standards rigor rigorous standards um
for off Lael uses and because the
expensive products would carry the
highest incentive for such activity
evidence poor prescribing would result
in runaway costs so in my last minute I
just want to talk a little bit about the
alternative which is the disclaimer
which is used a lot of times in court as
a way of trying to think of a less um
speech restricting alternative and this
has been required on dietary supplements
since the 1994 act although there's been
evidence of widespread failures in the
implementation of the of the desay
disclaimer we did a systematic review of
the literature um spanning a decade of
studies five randomized trials six
surveys and observational studies of the
DU disclaimer and we found that that the
results were clear that consumers are
unaware of the disclaimer or attach no
weight to it in their perceptions of the
product at issue so I would say this
disclaimer has a disclaimer that health
related disclaimers don't
work so so why don't they work they
don't work because recipients of
advertising messages are overwhelmed by
the totality and complexity of the
marketing messages studies show surveys
show that the majority of Americans
believe advertising associated with
health related products are generally
true um and Physicians and patients
don't understand the role of the FDA in
approving indications for prescription
drugs and the implications of a
prescription being off label um so the
the the prospect that FDA restrictions
on off Lael marketing would be replaced
with poorly effective disclaimers as
envisioned by the court and coron
risks returning the pharmaceutical
Marketplace to a previous era when such
inappropriate marketing claims
proliferated to the detriment of the
public health and then finally I want to
just mention that FDA regulation in this
area is already narrowly tailored
because of the numerous safe harbors
through which pharmaceutical
manufacturers can communicate to
Physicians um uh about their uh the off
Lael uses of their products for example
responding to unsolicited questions by
physicians supporting independent and
non-promotional CME programs engaging in
both bonified scientific dialogues like
we're doing here um these Pathways try
to encourage useful evidence-based
manufactur sponsored communication so
there is no way that a physician is in
the dark about an evidence-based
reasonable off-label use of their
product so I think it's worth resisting
the reasoning in coronia years of
experience with industry marketing
practices leads to dangerous
non-evidence based off label uses of
medical products justifies the need for
regulation in this area and again I just
want to leave you with this quote from
former Chief Justice anquist that there
are sufficient dangers attending the
widespread use of drugs that they simply
may not be promoted in the same manner
as hair creams deodorants and toothpaste
unfortunately this was in The Descent in
in in the Virginia pharmacy thank
you death sure there you
go so um let me start with the
confession uh bill and I are sort of on
both sides of this issue uh we both
misspent our our youth our young our
early part of our practice days at
public citizen litigation Group which
litigated the pharmacy board I then
wrote the brief in zou and argued
edenfield versus Fame so we've seen this
Doctrine from the other side as I would
point out chief judge kazinski chief
judge kazinski in 1976 wrote a very
influential law review article called
who's afraid of commercial speech sort
of challenging those people people and
there were many like the Chief Justice
who were critical of the Advent of the
uh commercial speech Doctrine so I want
to start just by tracing what I think
has been the wrong turn in this Doctrine
when when when the commercial speech
Doctrine sort of you know grew out of
Pharmacy Board there really were only
two types of cases that were covered one
were efforts by private plists to break
up government sponsored cartels so
Pharmacy Board was was the case to break
up uh the limitations on Advertising a
prescription price medication in order
to ensure there would be no competition
Bates zou these were lawyer advertising
cases to ensure that lawyers didn't
compete Licor Mart Kors liquor
advertising in order to dampen price
competition edenfield versus feain was
to keep literally the rule that was an
issue was called the anti- poaching rule
to keep CPAs from poaching one another's
clients or cases to dampen down uh
demand for what were viewed as Sin
products like alcohol gambling and state
mandated lotteries I think the court
took a wrong turn in a case that has
enormous uh I think enormous
significance for this conference which
is Thompson versus Western Medical
Center this was a case challenging the
Constitution and the compounding law
that permitted Compounders to uh to
engage in essentially drug production so
long as they did didn't advertise the
court split
54 with the majority holding that the
advertising restriction was
unconstitutional and to the extent that
there were non-speech means to control
the growth of this industry they ought
to be tried first if you look at Justice
Brier's descent he forecasts exactly
what happened to the compounding
industry which is it took off it was
able to advertise had an explosive
growth and the state regulation of
compounding as we now know today was
inadequate giving substance to all the
fears that Congress had when it passed
the law restricting the advertising so I
think part of the concern that I have is
this Doctrine which started out as a
genuinely intermediate standard of
review has morphed over time now why
should we care about food marketing this
is one of the advertising that the Palm
wonderful people use to promote their
product and I'm going to come back to it
but it's you know it is true that foods
and to some extent dietary supplements
pose somewhat less of a health concern
than drugs but not completely many of
the if you walked into a grocery store
five years ago it would be hard at times
to differentiate the sales pitches there
from the sales pitches in in a drugstore
um many foods were promoted on as having
really important Health attributes
including those that fit the definition
that bill started out with what
constitutes drug claims and so when in
2009 the FTC started bringing a series
of cases challenging the validity of
Health claims made on a huge list of
consumer products which most of the
people in this room consume at some
point in time Kelloggs mini frosted way
Wheats uh rice krispy uh Dean and yogurt
Activia you may remember those Jamie Lee
Curtis commercials with the arrow
pointing down
none of that was true the Coggs uh
advertisements that if you gave your
four-year-old Rice Krispies they
wouldn't get the flu right in advance of
the H1N1 flu uh Nestle's claiming the
probiotics that they sold for kids would
somehow prevent
influenza um sensea little you sprinkle
something on your food and you would
lose weight um but the case that's most
interesting because it's been fully
litigated is the Palm case this is a
case by the Federal Trade Commission
challenging explicit health benefit
claims prevention of arterial sclerosis
a treatment of prostate disease a
treatment of erectile dysfunction these
were a very aggressive advertisements
making what are classic drug claims now
it's a food and pomegranate juice is a
nutritious juice of course Palm juice is
is somewhat altered but it's there's no
you know it's not going to kill
um but you do pay a huge amount for it
and it was advertised deliberately if
you look at the claims so heart disease
prostate cancer and Ed uh four out of
five of the panel members uh were the
target audience of
pal um and they sold their products at a
very high price and they were very
successful and so you know the ftc's
Mandate is to uh prohibit to the extent
it can
of false and deceptive advertising in
the marketplace and so the Palm case is
a very rich case Erin would you mind
pulling up um it's it's can you can you
do that sure um go up a little there's
some really wonderful claims um and you
know the wonderful thing about this case
is this is a closely held Corporation
yeah I love this one is can you make
this bigger um uh this is a couple Stu
and Linda Resnik who are
multi-billionaire s they've made their
Fortune with Franklin Mint Tora they
sell Fiji Water which at least at one
point was literally imported from Fiji
um uh but they also were great marketers
so seven seven uh yes cheap death um oh
six FL you know flusher arteries is a
good one um but so these were these
these products were making quite
explicit uh disease prevention and cure
claims and we brought an enforcement
action against them one thing that you
need to
see is that uh these cases consume an
enormous amount of
resources um yeah I love these oh yeah
we there are tons of these we could
spend literally all day oh why don't you
go to 21 which is off to save prostates
um um and so part of part of the problem
with these marketing claims is that the
federal government spends a fortune
trying to to get these claims off the
market uh we sued um pal uh we had a
three-month long administrative trial
involving dozens of experts uh lots and
lots of scientific evidence and unlike
in private litigation the government
does not have the burden of of proof at
least in the initial phase of these
hearings the burden of proof is on the
company to substantiate their claims on
the grounds that these are essentially
Credence Goods these SE are Goods that
consumers cannot fairly evaluate on
their own given their taste or other
qualities and if you're going to make a
claim particularly a health claim of the
kind that that uh that that pal was
making you needed to have a reasonable
basis for it and of course there were
tons of studies that P did virtually all
of which were negative but pal Cherry
Picked portions of studies that were
they claimed supportive of their claimed
and we fought about it the case is now
pending in the DC circuit um and I
checked this morning fortunately they
did not rule it was argued in May um and
but there are a lot there are a number
of really difficult legal issues that
are embedded in this case for example
they put on some evidence of
substantiation who ultimately Bears the
burden of proof their argument is that
under the first amendment in order for
us to both punish them for their prior
claims of course we don't have any
punitive sanctions
but in order to enjoin them for making
similar claims in the future we
ultimately bear the burden of proof um
do you need extrinsic evidence of claim
interpretation if you go back to
decompress their argument was that
doesn't really make a drug claim even
though the claim is that using drinking
pomegranate juice every day will lead to
a 30% reduction in the clogging material
in your arteries Aon can give you a more
uh medical terminology for this but you
know it unclogs your arteries um and so
you know so there was a lot of dispute
about that and but the question is is
this does this claim make a health claim
or not and one argument they made which
has never really been conclusively been
resolved by the court is whether the
commission needs to put on survey
evidence from consumers finding what the
true meaning of this claim is there were
64 claims that issue in this case had we
done survey evidence for each one the
agency would have been broke um there's
another issue that's going to be teed up
in many of these cases which is what is
the remedial power of an agency or a
court so we all know what the at least
we we think we know what the standards
are to judge restraints on speech for
people who have not yet been adjudicated
to have violated the law
but in this case part of Pal's argument
is that the standards to be applied in
judging future representations about
these very products ought to be the same
as judging their
previous uh representations about this
claim that is the First Amendment
analysis should be
identical this issue is going to come up
in pal but it also is going to come up
in a variety of other cases for example
judge Kessler and I know the there's
going to be the next panel on uh on
Tobacco but this is a an issue that cuts
across the regulatory uh the whole swath
of regulatory agencies which is what are
the standards to be applied in a
remedial order so for example in the
tobacco case judge Kessler has ordered
the tobacco companies to publish ads
that among other things acknowledg that
they deliberately lie to the American
people and the question is what is the
first amendment test to judge those
kinds of orders is it Central Hudson is
it Zer is it some other standard is
there any what what what regulatory
lawyers call fencing in relief that that
Demands a lower standard of of First
Amendment review we've argued that
fencing in relief does allow us to place
real restraints on what pal says about
these products in the future assuming
that it can't produce evidence that
substantiates its claims um that issues
before the DC circuit in our case it
will be teed up again in the appeal
that's currently pending from Judge
Kessler's remedial order but it's an
interesting question that has not yet
really definitively been resolved by the
[Applause]
courts uh I want to thank uh Davis for
reminding me about that article I long
time ago uh with Stu Banner um who now
teaches at
UCLA um and um uh I was the first name
on the article and Stuart was the second
so you know he wrote most of it so I I I
blame him for um but I have in fact uh
I'm sorry one more disclaimer one
disclaimer I must make it clear because
there are pending cases uh I am not
commenting on any pending case I'm not
allowed to comment on anying case and I
don't mean to comment on any pain the
case so these are just my thoughts after
doing this for many decades and I guess
I join what I heard some of my co-
panelists say so my my in my enthusiasm
for uh unbridled First Amendment uh
protection of commercial speech uh has
waned somewhat over the years in light
of experience I am still there I still
feel the same way I still see the theory
but experience has sort of taught me to
be more skeptical and I'm not going to
say I would come out differently on some
of these cases if I were to hear him now
but I perhaps give it a um uh a second
thought and I I want to talk about uh
from uh by by actually referring to a
case that I was on and that that um uh
in 2002 and uh and having seen it and
having um then um seen how it's played
out uh it's not always the case that you
can see the sort of effects of your
rulings uh you sort of look track of
cases but in this case I actually see it
this is the case of con conand versus
Walters and some of you here might know
what the cas is but I I'm guessing some
many do not so let me just remind you
this was California uh passed a um
initiative in I think
1996 uh making it legal under state law
uh to uh use marijuana for medical
purposes and um it was an initiative it
wasn't passed by leg was in the ballot
and The Way It Was Written it um
essentially it's Exempted from state law
of criminal law anybody who use
marijuana according to a prescription by
a doctor or a recommendation by a doctor
and um of course um in so far as it
required the prescription doctors were
very uh you know
highly regulated in how they could write
prescriptions and I believe at that time
I believe today there are no legitimate
prescription uses for marijuana I I
think uh there was a compassionate uh uh
use uh program uh that slowly waned uh
the federal government got rid of it but
I think there was no uh authority to
write prescriptions uh but doctors were
free to
recommend and um uh the state was
getting ready to implement the law a
federal government came along and
started investigating doctors uh for
doing recommendation and the penalty for
doing that would be that if there were
viewed as sort of uh um abusing the the
the the the recommendation Authority or
they they uh they were recommending it
in a way that was inconsistent with the
way the federal government thought they
should be doing it that they could have
their prescription Authority
the authority to write prescriptions
taken away of course you can't be a
doctor without being able to write
prescriptions I mean it's it's silly so
so that was a pretty substantial Hammer
so this was this was brought in District
Court in in in San Francisco and
District Court entered an injunction and
it entered an injunction against the
federal government
investigating conducting a criminal
investigation actually uh investigating
um um for uh doctor for for these abuses
of these what thought to be abuses and
the case came to us uh and we affirmed
uh it was a very happy panel for uh uh
for the doctors um uh then Chief jut
schro was on the panel um and my
colleague um my for my now passed away
colleague Betty Fletcher and and I and I
think it's fair to say this was about as
as sympathetic a first amend panel as
you could get may have been if some in
the ninth circuit they would be equally
sympathetic but I don't think you could
have done much better and in fact they
got the result that uh that could have
been expected and uh it was a very fine
opinion written by judge
schroer uh that was focusing on the
right of the doctors to give advice the
doctors give advice and uh uh when when
when they have views and they want to
discuss something with their clients
they have a right to speak and have a
right to make their views known and the
First Amendment does not permit the
government to burden that right by going
and investigating and then possibly
putting them a Jeopardy of the license
uh I wrote an impassioned concurrence uh
saying uh yes the right of the doctors
is important uh but what really is at
stake here is the right of the patients
to hear uh if doctors can't
speak you know it's not such a big deal
for them I mean uh you know obviously
they want to be able to speak but
they're not going to put their license
on the line uh in order to be able to
sort of give advice uh uh it just it
just doesn't make any sense but from the
perspective of the patients the ability
to hear advice and um the parties in
thei had many documentated documented
instances where use of marijuana uh
could be beneficial or was s to be
beneficial for any number of things uh
uh people who were under CH chemotherapy
Y and had no appetite this gave him an
appetite there's a whole list of things
nausea from from various drugs that dis
familiar and so on so the idea um in my
concurrence was that the ability of uh
patients to hear this advice from the
doctors uh and and act on it so so that
they can make an informed decision as to
whether to use this for which now would
be legal under under under under state
law uh to amarate their their their um
medical
symptoms their medical problems would
would be uh you know exceedingly
important and if they didn't get this
advice they would resort to the internet
and you can only say resort to the
internet and sort of damn something by
uh essentially they would have to rely
on Word of Mouth U the you know internet
their friends and so on rather than
relying on a on a
professional uh somebody who who went to
medical school who knows their condition
and who can give informed advice as to
whether this would be not be a good
thing so so really what's at stake here
is the right of the of the of the
patient to hear and obtain you uh
information that is key to the patient's
own health and uh well-being and you
know as I say this I am so moved by it
that I
[Laughter]
persuaded once again I I I I think I
think I was so
right but here's the reality I we've now
lived with this now this was 2002 it's
coming to the fact of the matter is the
way this operates is if you want to
smoke pot in California there are places
you can go down walk in and get a
certificate from a doctor saying you
need it medically
period how do I know this trust me I
know
it um and and so this is not you know as
I and I'm speaking out for my colleagues
but I think it's a fair inflence I think
what the idea we had was the idea that
you know here comes a patient um perhaps
with AIDS or suffering with chemother
you know taking chemotherapy or or you
know variety of ailments uh uh that were
listed that and goes to the doctor and
doctor says well I've looked at your
record I'm going to do some tests I'm
going to think about it I'm here's my
advice I think there's something good
for you to do and that's what we had in
mind that's not what's happening at all
what's happening at all is a few doctors
who've made a business of giving out
certificates and I've seen these
certificates so it look like things you
could put on the wall uh it's got a
little seal on them and uh they are made
for one purpose and one purpose only if
you're driving along the highway and you
get stopped and the officer says hey
what's uh is that
a baggy of marijuana on the front seat
and you say yes officer and that's
because I have a certificate and you
show the certificate and he's got to let
you
go
now is that a bad result uh I don't know
and I guess
if a state wants to Simply decriminalize
marijuana I don't I'm I'm an agnostic on
that score I think probably we regulate
drugs too much and so I'm I'm for it in
general but it's this deception that
bothers me the idea which I think many
people in California buy into is that
this is somehow done under the aaces of
medical
advice uh it I think is true in some
cases and I actually do know people who
are uh who are um who are um having
chemotherapy uh who do get advice from
the doctors and who do in fact get the
marijuana in the same way in the way in
which we
anticipated but the reality is that it
is uh it is it is now being used uh
essentially to circumvent all
regulation and what bothers me and again
I have not really changed my mind I just
want to thr up a flag of skepticism is
that the power of the First Amendment
um to affect substantive changes in the
way we uh uh conduct uh just various
aspects of our of of of uh uh life and
commerce uh think about uh baits I was
there to see Bill cambi uh argue baits I
was at the at the court and actually
remember seeing him so Ruth Ginsburg
argued it was a great term um but uh it
was uh and I was all for it and I guess
I'm still all for it but then I when I'm
on the freeway and I see those ads for
abogado doors doors doors do do do doors
you know and you know am I I just wonder
is is the public or the is is the legal
professional the public better off uh s
of the claims that if you just let
people advertise uh more will be learned
and people will be wiser or make wiser
decision it is really true I don't know
I'm still I say on the S side of the
fence uh I'm still in favor of uh the
speech but I have gotten a little closer
to the middle thank you very
much okay so I'd like to invite you if
you have a a question just come up to
and line up behind the U microphones and
um I will just start us off um with a
question um first of all thanks for the
very Illuminating remarks um I think
many of you have touched on the part of
the impetus for the conference right
which is the migration of commercial
speech Doctrine in particular um and to
me one way of characterizing uh kind of
common theme between some of the things
we've been talking about on this panel
is that you have a set of cases that
were developed in a context where we
knew what was true and people were not
allowed to say it right the price of a
particular commodity right uh where you
could go to get a commodity something
like that and now we're talking about a
series of cases where we don't know
what's true and it's actually extremely
hard to know what's true is a drug safe
or effective for this or that purpose or
is pomegranate juice going to save us
all or not right and so that just seems
to me to raise a whole host of issues
that just were not present in the
Genesis of this commercial speech
Doctrine one way to characterize what
the government is doing either the FTC
or the FDA is saying we have to we have
to create some regulation you know not
because we don't want people to say what
we know is true because we don't know
what's true right and so creating a set
of burdens and Regulatory structures to
say let's produce information let's
force people to produce information and
here's the best people to produce it uh
and that seems to me a very potentially
a very different kind of Regulation than
some of the others that we've talked
about it also raises really interesting
issues about the competence of Courts um
versus say agencies to evaluate these
kinds of questions right so you know in
coronia the court says well we don't
worry uh the FDA law may be
unconstitutional but you know you can
still show that the claims are false
well you know so you go to a court and
you say well this claim made in this
particular you know by this drug rep is
false um you know how is I mean that
raises Palm wonderful is exactly that
kind of case and the court has to say
well what's false and how much evidence
do I need to know that it's false what
if there's one study that has Bears no
relationship to sort of what the FDA
would do when you go to an FDA set of
you know scientific panel and you have
to produce all this evidence right so
how do we think about I guess in this
sense both the the you know Court versus
regulatory body question and also ought
we think differently about some of these
kind of information forcing cases than
we do about your generic kind of
commercial speech case where you know
everybody knows what's
true all right you were looking at me
I'll start off I mean part of the
question you're asking is who Bears the
risk of uncertainty one of the reasons
why when we pushed the cases that we did
in the dietary sub in the food marketing
field is we we tried to drive home that
these are really classic Credence Goods
these are not Goods that consumers can
evaluate the claims on their own they
have to rest to some extent on the
veracity of the marketer's claims and
you know it's not just the hard claims
so for example we have cases against
dietary sub manufacturers who may claims
that if you lie on your couch eating
whatever you eat you don't exercise but
you take their magic pill you're going
to lose 10 pounds a week and they have a
study you know a study produced by
someone who claims to have a PhD that
supports that and we have to go to court
with our experts and prove that that
that substantiation is not accurate and
so for Regulators the cases in in which
there is uncertainty which are the these
days probably the Lion Share of the
cases create really very difficult
enforcement problems you know Bill is
right when I was at the FDA we probably
did a 100 dietary subc cases we could
have done a thousand dietary subcases
and we'd still be doing them we picked
the biggest manufacturers we went after
basic research and Lane Labs iovate sort
of the big the big sellers but you know
and so the the the the price we pay is a
Marketplace that's Rife with misleading
claims about health some more
significant than others drug claims I
think pose a greater risk to to human
health than than claims about foods that
are not going to kill you but probably
are not going to prevent you from
getting prostate cancer or treat your
heart disease or cure rectile
dysfunction and you know I think the
courts are now starting to sort out
these kinds of more difficult questions
that's why it's so interesting to see
what the Court's going to do in the Palm
case we were you know we were happy to
litigate at that case because no one
wants the answers to the questions that
you've posed more than the Regulatory
Agencies David I I'm wondering to what
extent are do you think
consumers uh uh less likely to be
skeptical because they think you are out
there doing this kind of thing and to to
to what extent they more likely be
deceived because they say well they
couldn't say this if it wer to I think
that with respect to Food and Drugs
there is the presumption that the
government would not allow these
products to be marketed with these
claims unless there was some formal
approval process and there's survey
evidence that the FDA has done that bill
that bill
knows let me um so years ago there was a
very popular cancer treatment called
leil oh yes and it and um it was made
from apricot pits and there was a real
following
and the FDA said look this is an
unapproved drug uh intended use and all
of that and it was litigated went
through the ninth circuit it went up to
the Supreme Court and ultimately the
Supreme Court upheld the FDA and said
you know you've got to prove it well
this was so popular that after that uh
the National Institutes of Health paid I
don't know how much but it was probably
tens of millions of dollars to do a
study and the study ultimately show
showed that it was not effective but I
just say that for an example as an
example I mean the idea that the
government can affirmatively go come
into court and show that a claim is
misleading is just not realistic because
in this area as opposed to drug prices
or some of these other areas you
actually have to do the study to prove
it's not misleading you usually just
don't know it might be a theory you know
maybe maybe apricot piss did cure cancer
you you couldn't find that out until you
spent millions and millions of dollars
and so that sort of Regulation I just
don't think would ever work let me just
add one thing you know ay berries uh
there were popular shows o for winry Dr
Oz they all had shows touting aide
berries were going to help you lose
weight sales of as side berries went
through the roof there's no scientific
support for any of this um and there
have now been clinical studies done that
show that there is no weight loss
benefit from eating aside berries but
it's a very sticky thing when you have
uh you know popular uh people using
their platforms and their social media
platforms to disseminate this kind of
information lra might still be sold you
know had it come through that process
yeah if it were a dietary supplement it'
still be
sold I imagine David you're sort of
unpopular because you come here and you
tell all of us that these things we
thought were actually really healthy for
I until I read the I was very depressed
when I read the pal case because I
actually did think pomegranate juice was
pretty good for you um so it turns out
asai berries are also have to be crossed
off my list yeah and green coffee as
well sorry
okay so hi so you know we can talk about
First Amendment Dr and all we want and
since you're lawyers who can do that but
um we have to put this in political
context too if you look at the end of
David Carpenter's book on the FDA
there's been a 30 year war of attrition
on the FDA in terms of the Washington
Legal Foundation the Goldwater Institute
and a whole host of other sort of very
well-backed advocates for dismantling
the regulatory stateus it it revolves
around drugs you start to read these
cases and you wonder what kind of
credence that the public health and the
medical professions get in some of these
these these judicial rulings and I'm
wondering as a public health
professional how do we play some role in
this debate that's happening in a sphere
that doesn't really take our expertise
in into give it that much weight how do
we affect this debate which is largely
happening on somebody else's
terrain um well I mean I think I think
that there is you know a a great deal of
misconception in a lot of these cases
about what a uh about what a physician
and you know and what the medical
community is able to whether or not
they're able to call um truth from what
is truth and what isn't truth and I
think way one way that the Public Health
Community can help add to that debate is
by pointing out the consequences of
getting that decision wrong I mean as
opposed to the Palm cases and you know I
mean that if you when you get the case
wrong with the case of a drug that will
kill you and that will kill a lot of
people and um you know so it it's even
more essential to have a process by
which we can generate reliable evidence
and then um make sure that it is
disseminated correctly to uh to
Physicians um so you know I mean I think
that you know a lot of in a lot of legal
cases we talk about the physician as a
learned intermediary in a way and I
think that we need to think of the FDA
as a learned intermediary to The
Physician because without the fda's
guidance on on what you know and what is
approved and unapproved in
evidence-based and not evidence-based
you know Physicians have a a really
tough time trying to make that those
same kinds of of
decisions
Kevin Samy your point about we don't
know the truth of this in the same way
that we we know the truth about the
pricing of of liquor and whatnot but of
course a lot of the rest of the first
amendment was there for things for which
we didn't have Clear Proof you know
religion and you know political
philosophy so this almost occupies an
intermediate place where where we need
scientific proof to establish something
but it is provable but it requires a lot
of investment to get there um I wonder
if uh you know Bill's comments were
focused a lot on the intentionality
standard and I wonder if that does much
you know for the for judge kazinski um
you know we're not Prosecuting here
speech we're using speech as evidence
that they're intending to Market this as
a drug and if that distinction goes away
in some of these cases um I don't know
how we defend any pre-market approval
you know I mean why why is the second
approval the one that's at risk why
isn't the first approval at risk you
know for any device or drug if we don't
you know make a stand on this
intentional ality question is that a
useful
distinction we're not forbidding speech
we're just using it as evidence of an
intent to Market a
drug
well but you are preventing speech uh um
I mean the the the whole theory of I
remember baits and uh
um virgin phal was that uh people can't
use drugs uh if they don't understand or
or whatever the services law legal
services if they don't uh if they not
given the information that was the
theory uh we had in contact you know we
got to sort of give people information
uh to to uh to make informed decisions
and if you stop the flow of information
you're essentially stopping the the the
the use of the product um I I I don't
know I I I I think you're right I think
we will uh never have this be on the
same par as as political speech I mean
we have
Alvarez um where I wrote my opinion um
giving my uh Praise of lying uh the
importance of lying uh you know it's
probably true in real life uh their
ability to lie is important but it's
certainly not true in in marketing drugs
where where you can kill people with it
so I don't or political speech you know
we could
[Music]
never is a case pending now about this
uh uh you couldnot prosecute somebody I
think for for lying on a a political
campaign but uh but it would be uh uh uh
quite different with I don't think we'll
ever get in a to an area where this is
uh uh where these things are treated
like political speech or or personal
speech and the question is have we gone
too far uh in in in terms of uh in terms
of uh
um impeding uh what should be uh
important
regulations things that people simply
cannot cannot uh find out for themselves
you know
I there's sort of a flip side of this
and this is another stuff that that that
is prohib speaking uh there's all that
stuff on the on the foods now that
appear I think it was FTC that requires
nutritional information that's that's
the FDA that's bill I knew I know it was
one of these guys and I thought it was
stupid when it first came out but I use
it all the
time I do I mean I I I know compare
those little boxes and uh I don't know
how they get there but I I I assume
they're accurate and when they say so
many grams of sugar really does mean so
many grams of sugar and so it turns out
to be exceedingly useful
stuff uh not something I would have
thought would be the government should
require but now I'm sort of glad they do
so I was I was uh on the staff of the uh
Energy and Commerce Committee and I was
the staffer who wrote wrote that law but
let me tell you why it got through it
got it got it had bipartisan support
because we had many sort of 50 60 year
old members of Congress who were
offended by the fact that they could not
figure out how much sodium was in their
food and they that that's why it passed
they were
completely uh offended and and it it got
very very broad support and the carbs
carbs too but it was the salt that they
really cared about because they watching
their blood pressure now it's the car
yeah you know just on this I'm sorry go
ahead please um just on the the question
I mean we we think it's important that
the the speech prohibition here applies
to the manufacturer selling the product
it doesn't apply to anybody else who's
talking about it and so in that sense
that you know there's a an attempt to
make it very narrow I I think the
vulnerability and and and the thing
that's always really hard about this on
the so-called off Lael use is doctors
are free and it's really seen as an
important part of medical practice that
doctors can prescribe off label and yet
we're telling the manufacturers that
they can't talk about it and uh it's
very very tricky to kind of explain this
balance that that Congress has has drawn
you know to to try to preserve the
incentive to actually do the research
and yet let the doctors practice
medicine but that's the that's to me the
hardest part I just want to make a I
mean well cross cutting issues are going
to keep coming up in each of the panels
but some of the questions about medical
marijuana um will come up in our panel
tomorrow morning about the regulation of
professional speech and and some of
these issues about food labeling will
come up in our next panel because there
are really now very important issues
about the freedom that the government
has to in fact require labels um
particularly if those labels start to
condense information in a way that the
government thinks is helpful to
Consumers but that uh companies May
object to so please I think that might
be my my question waits for the next
panel but I was goingon to ask judge
kazinski you had a focus on the right of
the consumer to hear and the tests that
have developed seemed to focus more on
an intrusion on the right of the
commercial speaker and do you think that
focusing on the speaker is an
appropriate proxy for protecting the
consumer you know in so far as there are
sort of contiguous rights or
complimentary rights I think it it uh it
um somewhat close but I think it is
better to uh it would be more useful to
to uh to focus on the right to hear and
that might reach a different result I
mean it may be that
it's again not to speak to a particular
case it may be perfectly okay for uh the
uh or maybe appropriate from the point
of view of the patient for drug
companies to make available information
about off label use but that doesn't
mean they have to scream it it doesn't
mean they have to spend billions or
millions of dollars on it and again I I
don't want to comment on on any pending
cases but if you view it as the right of
the speaker to speak then you are uh
it's very hard to sort of set a limit on
it and say well if you right to speak
you have a right to speak if the
question is uh viewed from the
perspective of the consumer and that is
the right to get an informed decision
from his doctor then maybe the the the
balance would be different you let me
just add one thing if you look at
Pharmacy Board in the early cases the
perspective the court used was the right
of the listener not the right of the
speaker and the court was quite quite
emphatic about that and and I and I very
much agree with judge kazinski that that
the lens makes a big difference um there
was no speaker in Pharmacy Board there
were a bunch of old ladies who were
driving around Northern Virginia
comparing prices at pharmacies because
they couldn't otherwise find out what
the price of prescription drugs are and
you know and I think one of the
dangerous moves that's happened in the
commercial speech Doctrine and I think
your question really sort of nails it is
that at some point and I think Thompson
is really one of the key cases the court
really shifts its lens and is talking
about the rights of the speaker at the
same time the pharmacy board case was
being litigated drug Source were suing
challenging the same prohibition and
they lost they were making you know
essentially economic due process cases
they lost and the pharmacy board case
went up and you can see you can see in
the surrell case the extension of this
thinking to its next extreme which is is
that because in the cell case they
actually you know they apply a
heightened scrutiny above intermediate
scrutiny because of the speaker specific
restrictions in cell and well but but
that's the problem that bill is getting
at you know cell implies that that's a
Viewpoint discrimination and if and one
one concern I have about off Lael uses
is someone's going to make the argument
based on sell that all you're doing is
forbidding the manufacturer you're just
really drowning out one speaker the only
speaker who's restrained in a in in in a
on a landscape where everyone else can
speak and and I think I mean I think we
overread sorl for a variety of reasons
but I think that's a danger well and and
Justice Brier I think in his descent in
that case points out that this is all
commercial regulation and a lot of the
regulatory State targets just one kind
of speaker if you're regulating you know
utility companies it's only the utility
companies that you're regulating
everybody else can say x y or Z about
electricity but only so I mean this is a
much deeper problem than even just for
coronia okay um this
is this is a question for Aon I don't
know if this is on um it is it is on
just get your mouth closer to it no no
just be shorter be be shorter right so
it's easy eron something you emphasized
in your presentation but you didn't come
back to is that in in a Corona the court
jumped over the first prong of the um
Central Hudson test uh meaning that was
the speech misleading and one could make
the argument and I think you have in the
past that um one could argue that it is
misleading and so if you could just
comment on that sure thanks thanks uh
Leo um so I I mean I think that um in in
coronia I think that some of the things
that that coronia said certainly were
false and May and and misleading I think
the problem is is that when you get into
that kind of a debate in you you it you
know it necessarily UPS the anti in
terms of the amount of resources and the
amount of of debate over you know
between experts to try to figure out
what is or isn't truth and what is or
isn't correct and so you know if you
start trying to parse well was the
statement was the statements about
Parkinson's disease correct well you
know here's a 10 person case study that
was done in Japan showing um the effects
of this drug improved uh you know
disease symptoms in eight of the 10
people is that truth is that is that
correct um you know I think that that's
really hard to assess and so you know
it's a lot uh cleaner and and and more
straightforward for um for everybody
involved if the standard is on and off
label and I think that was the fda's
strategy in skipping over that hurdle in
uh in their arguments um uh before the
um in in the coronia case right but the
standard is it is it true and is it
misleading and that 10% study I mean do
you think that the that was a mistake
not to press on that first prong uh I
mean in retrospect yeah probably the FDA
is kicking itself a little bit that it
didn't uh make more hay out of whether
or not uh coronia had any support for
claiming that um that that this drug
that was used uh you know in date rape
is is in is actually a great insomnia
treatment um but I think that uh I I
think that nonetheless I think it's a
it's a sensible uh distinction for the
FDA to have made uh prospectively
unfortunately now going forward I think
that's what where where the FDA is going
to be dragged into is a lot of these
discussions over what is or isn't true
and it's going to you know severely
limit their resources in being in bring
in being able to bring these cases and
it's going to um you know cast a shadow
over negotiations and settling these
cases and it's going to be it's going to
make enforcement in this area a lot more
difficult
hi can you hear me any yeah you have to
be up you
know till till the till the
mic so I was wondering if there's
actually any constitutional distinction
between um drug manufacturers pushing
off label use um through drug reps and
then doing it through direct to Consumer
advertising if there is no constit
distinction how would that complicate
regulation of that
area well I I don't think there's a
constitutional distinction I will tell
you regulation of drug reps is very very
difficult as a practical
matter um for obvious reasons and and
that's why these cases typically are not
against the drug rep they're against the
company because the company has produced
training materials and other kinds of
evidence uh it's you know it's it's uh
and what happened in coron is they swept
in both the rep and the company and then
the as Aon said the company PL out so I
mean I I don't think that there's
constitutional difference I think that
if you're a drug company who is direct
to Consumer advertising off label uses
you are a pretty stupid Drug Company um
because that is a very public statement
about something that is at least for as
we sit here right now this minute not
something you are allowed to do um
uh so I think that a lot of the off Lael
promotion that goes on goes on in a
Subterranean way through drug reps and
through in this new era through um you
know Internet advertising and other
mechanisms that are less obvious to
regulators and so that's why a lot of
this tends to occur through um through
drug reps but let me just press the
point because I think if there isn't a
constitutional logic you know if coronia
were accepted then do we have to also
accept then it wouldn't be potentially
UNC constitutional to you know right now
outside of the second circuit you'd be
dumb to do this but you know that's
right yes how worried ought one be I
mean or is there a constitutional
argument that you could make that would
say okay well they're doing this to the
doctors but they can't go on national
television and Market drugs off label I
mean I think that as long as the current
scheme is in place that you can Market
on label products in direct to Consumer
fashion where you say you know here are
the you know in the in the the rules
that the that that exist and um the
statement that are made in those
contexts you know suggesting that you
see your doctor to ask him about
whatever I think that it I I don't see a
a way to prevent that from happening I
mean this is really you know such an
interesting area but another Nuance of
this if you think about it um the
advertising to Consumers I mean there's
a a decent argument that why should that
be so bad because the doctor has to make
the decision it's it's not like Palm or
some of these other cases where the
consumer is making its own decision so
that I think also really complicates the
analysis I mean I would say you know as
I I said in my talk in the second
circuit there is this Theory the second
circuit didn't decide that the
advertising is evidence of the intended
use and you know that's still I think
open to argue and undecided well
marketing the consumer does
have uh a collateral risk and that is
having a consumer who gets the drug
for a prescribed
purpose uh that may be legitimate uh and
then she's advertising and then without
consulting the doctor goes and use the
the uh the non-prescribed use and
depending on what the drug is it may be
the kind of drug that the doctor won't
even give a second thought to because uh
you know let's say it's blood pressure
medicine and just routinely renew the
prescription so if you if you mark to
that segment of the community say you
take your blood pressure medicine and it
can make your hair grow uh you know you
kill blondness it's not that's not so
far a fetched either thank goodness yeah
an oxidil was originally a blood
pressure pill okay let me just make one
point there you
go let me make one point that I think
you heard it here first
folks only you heard it here first I
would in here you know there's one
there's one point that shouldn't get
lost which is there are more
comprehensive regulation of face-to-face
encounters than the FDA does with drug
detail men and doctors there are other
you know the SEC has all sorts of rules
about face-to-face encounters and
certain contacts contacts uh many states
still prohibit direct in-person
solicitation by lawyers post toic so I
you know there I think there is a
constitutional difference whether it
matters very much I doubt
it okay this I think this comes at this
question from another uh perspective a
little bit and Dr kesim this is this is
mostly targeted to you I think um
because I appreciate the distinction in
the regulatory scheme between allowing
doctors to prescribe off label and to
find out about uh medical advances
through their professional organizations
and clinical trials Etc while
controlling the marketing off label but
I think it's created a
confusion um maybe because of the
regulatory structure I don't know but
when States now are stepping in and
regulating for example in the area of
medical abortion they're regulating
based on what's on label and off label
it's created a huge amount of confusion
in the courts and I think in the minds
of the public about what's appropriate
what's scientifically valid Etc so I
don't know if there's what if you think
there's a sort of regulatory fix for
that or if there's another kind of
approach that that might help sure uh in
that context yeah I mean I think it's a
great question and I and I didn't mean
to I didn't mean to apply in imply in my
comments at any point that something
just just because something's off label
it means that it is not evidence-based
or not true I think there yeah I think
there are plenty of off Lael uses that
have evidence uh behind them and I think
that there you know in in the current
situation you know there is a uh in a
current regulatory environment it's it's
you know relatively difficult to get an
off label use that Garners enough
evidence that it then would become a you
know theoretically be an on-label uh or
FDA approved use you know there's it
still takes a lot of resources and uh in
order to get that through the FDA I
think that one one mechanism one
regulatory mechanism that could uh you
know help solve that problem is if there
was some sort of expedited pathway
through which the FDA could review off
Lael uses of a product evidence-based
off Lael uses of a product to supplement
a lab a either in looking at their you
know in supplemental uh um evidence
related to safety or or even the
efficacy of the drug so you know right
now it requires the manufacturer in most
cases to come forward and present that
information to the FDA and to pay a fee
and whatever else um you know if there
were you know accelerated ways of doing
this then uh you know that might help
build a label that better reflects the
uh current state of the evidence rather
than you know whatever was fixed at the
time uh that either the drug was
approved or um you know whenever the
last update was I have a quick followup
question to that Erin so um has there
been any attempt to analogize the
situation to the stuff you've written
about about um monitoring experimental
drugs once they're already in the market
you know so these sort of post Market
post use uh data
collection practices and then separately
I had heard that in the cancer context
there are something called this cancer
compendium where uh the Consortium gets
to approve a bunch of off label products
for use and insurers tend to reimburse
without off label use so how does that
fit in if if you know if you don't sure
specific question how does it fit into
this whole spectum of what we've been
talking about yeah so there is you know
there are these compendia that you're
talking about and I uh you know I think
that and the the comp what the compendia
do is they get together a lot of very
expert oncologists and they look at all
the use you know the evidence around
uses of a particular cancer product and
they list you know apart from the uh
uses that are on the label all the other
evidence-based uses of this particular
chemotherapy agent and um CMS and uh
private insurers use this to figure out
which off Lael uses of the drugs they're
going to approve um you know whether or
not a pharmaceutical company can uh
Market about those products in the
current environment probably they can't
probably directly Market about them no
um but they you know there are there is
there is a mechanism actually through
which drug companies another Safe Harbor
that I didn't list in which drug
companies can talk to formularies um
about uh about coverage of Agents um you
know uh in these kinds of circumstances
and not where they're not talking to
physicians in this case they're talking
to you know a different environment and
again this get gets back to some things
that people have discussed about about
who the listeners are in which again
these cases and in the case of you know
this you know this Safe Harbor because
the listener is thought to be a more um
you know s a higher body in of a
formulary committee that's made up of a
bunch of Physicians and is making policy
decisions about a whole group that the
you know the fact that it's an off Lael
uh indication not officially in the FDA
label is not uh considered to be a
barrier and so pharmaceutical companies
can actually talk through this Safe
Harbor and I can talk more about it
offline but um I mean I think that there
again it just kind of provides more
evidence to the fact that just because
something is off label doesn't doesn't
mean that there's no way for Physicians
to learn about it or for uh the drug to
get used in an evidence-based way if um
you know if drug companies are not
allowed to talk about
it I have a question about the the
misleading element of the first prong of
the Central Hudson test um because we
sort of the case is typically focus on
the the words themselves um and sort of
asemantic uh inquiring to the meaning
conveyed to the listener but I'm sort of
wondering as we get more and more
evidence that the vehicle matters you
know that consumers are more persuaded
by an actor in a white coat than an
actor in a Cowboy head that doctors are
more persuaded by a very attractive and
flirtatious drug grip than by a glossy
pamphlet whether um that might make a
difference for the analysis because you
know the court say over and over again
that just because the message is
persuading uh is sort of persuasive to
The Listener that doesn't make it
automatically misleading but if we're
sort of seeing that it's not so much
about the message but how it's conveyed
that can make people be persuaded in
ways they didn't realize they were being
persuaded that that kind of sort of
Behavioral psychology element might at
some point produce enough empirical data
to make make it sort of provably
misleading even though the words haven't
changed so let me take that one on um
first of all the first prong of Central
Hudson is not the kind of get out of
jail free card for regulatory agents as
you might think because they have the
burden at that stage in order to sort of
dispense with the remainder of the
Central Hudson test and they're really
the the world of claims really sort of
divides neatly into two different
packages one are Express claims those
are claims in which the the words are
clear and there's no dispute about the
meaning of the claim and that you know
those claims are either are often easily
provable false or not but then there are
implied claims a lot of the claims that
P made were implied claims they were
also what we call establishment claims
because they they boasted they were
supported by medical evidence and on
those claims the the the government has
the burden of interpretation and while
the courts give some degree of deference
to the agency um it's it's not
conclusive and so sometimes in cases
where there's an implied claim the
burden is on the agency to prove that
you know a significant percentage of
consumers understand the claim in a way
that's misleading and we do uh you know
conser a surveys and get other evidence
to support uh our enforcement actions
when we go after implied claims I don't
know whether that's fully responsive to
your question but so just as a let's say
a company makes a claim take this drug
use it off label it will reduce your
risk of prostate cancer and they've got
a single study and it's in 50 people and
it actually showed that but anybody in
this field would know that that's just
not enough people it's not statistically
significant it's really not valid but
FDA can't prove its misleading because
it really doesn't know the studies
haven't been done so to me that that
first prong of Central Hudson at least
in the drug area area is really of
limited utility yeah and at the FTC we
would take a slightly different position
which is and we we don't we don't do the
labels we do the ads but not for
prescription drugs we take the position
that unless there was some
substantiation Beyond this weak study
they would have to qualify that claim
they'd have to make a claim that that
says there's a preliminary study and we
don't know whether it's valid and uh and
qualified in a way that they wouldn't
make the claim probably but that's under
your substantiation standard that's
under our substantiation standard I
think some some of issues related to
your question J will come up in the next
panel when we'll be talking about cases
where there are um say disclosures
required or graphic warning labels on
cigarettes and courts have explicitly
started to contemplate whether or not
the emotive nature of the warning or so
forth actually ought to make a
difference in First Amendment term so I
think that'll converge actually quite
nicely with this discussion um so our
next panel begins in uh about 10 minutes
minutes so we'll take a quick break and
please join me in thanking our fantastic
[Applause]
panelist a lot bet somebody uses the
nutrition
sorry cont
um okay everybody uh my name is Abby
Gluck I teach health law here at the law
school we couldn't be more thrilled to
have such a fantastic turnout at one of
our many wonderful Health event so thank
you to Robert and Amy for organizing
this fantastic conference again um
we're going to try to keep this panel as
Rowdy as the last one maybe even a
little rowdier uh one of our panelist
Christine jeles is on route and we'll be
Waltzing in sometime in the middle of
the panel hope and we will make sure we
accommodate her schedule when she gets
here um so this panel is on health
behaviors and the basic theme of the
panel is to look at the use of Public
Health campaigns or other strategies
that are designed to influence people's
choices on matters relating to health
things like calorie count efforts
graphic cigarette warning campaigns and
mandatory ultrasound viewing laws and
our panelists are going to talk about
these and a lot more so we have a
wonderful distinguished and very
interdisciplinary panel for this
conference uh they have very long bios
I'm going to give a very brief version
so we save the time for them and not for
me uh in order of they will be speaking
to my left is Kelly brell who's the dean
of the Stanford School of public policy
at Duke he's the Robert L flowers
professor of public policy professor of
Psychology and Neuroscience as you all
know he's a nationally renowned expert
on food policy and obesity among other
things he's a member of The Institute of
medicine has been called time magazines
among the world's most 100 influential
people and before he left for Duke we
had the Good Fortune of having him here
at Yale where he ran the uh very widely
respected red Center for food policy and
obesity which I had the pleasure of
doing some work with in my time in
government um then Nadia was saying to
Kelly's left Nadia swii is a law
professor at Lola Chicago Law School
she's an expert on health law and
bioethics she has degrees in both from
the University of Pennsylvania Nadia's
research focuses on the appropriate use
of persuasion by state actors uh the
Law's recognition of legal rights to
recovery for invasion of contested harms
and definitions of professional roles
and ethical Norms in medicine articles
have been published in a variety of very
interdisciplinary journals ranging from
the Pennsylvania law reviews
constitutional law volume to the New
England Journal of Medicine um Christine
joles is the missing link uh she's the
Gordon Bradford twey professional and
law and organization here at Yale she
also happens to be the director of the
law and economics program at the
National Bureau of economic research in
Cambridge where she's coming from right
now uh she's a graduate of Harvard a PhD
from MIT and economics former law clerk
Justice Scalia on the Supreme Court and
she's a nationally recognized expert in
a variety of areas but it's particularly
relevant to this panel she's a expert in
behavioral law and economics and finally
Ted merman at the very left is the
co-founder and direct executive director
of the public good Law Center where he
litigates consumer protection First
Amendment and civil rights cases for the
past decade prior to founding public
good had served for eight years as a
deputy attorney general in California
where he aranged in a wide array of
high-profile litigation efforts on
consumer issues and he also wrote many
amikas briefs on behalf of the State of
California and many other states on
areas directly related to this panel
including deceptive advertising to
Tobacco promotion and digital marketing
he's a graduate of Berkeley law school
as well of a as a very small College
here in New Haven Connecticut um yeah
yes okay so uh with that uh we will
start with Kelly and uh you will have
Julian in the stripe shirt will give you
a 12 minute signal and that'll be a
three minute warning to the all right
thank you I'm delighted to be here I was
pleased to be asked to come to the
meeting and to be with so many
distinguished legal minds and other
people in public health to talk about
issues of great concern to the public
good um I the reason I'm really here
today is to plead with you to plead with
you to pay attention to the issues that
we're going to be talking about on this
panel because there hasn't been enough
legal attention paid to them over the
years and I think it's really hurt our
field not in a negative way but it's
nice that the um that the legal
profession is now paying attention and I
think we can accomplish a lot as Abby
said in my introduction I'm at Duke
University after being at Yale for 23
years um the picture that you see here
uh on the left is the Sanford School of
Public Policy where I now live and in
the foreground there is the the Duke Law
School so which is right across the
street from us so that establishes is
the extent of my legal credentials the
law school is right across the street so
I'm really going to talk about this from
a public health point of view and try to
set the food marketing to children in in
context uh behind the yellow the the
orange boxes that you see there you're
going to see the expected increases in
diabetes in the US India and China
between now and in the year 2030 in the
US we're expecting this kind of an
increase which is really alarming given
the high base rate we have diabetes
already but in China the numbers will
look like this and in India the numbers
will look like this so when we talk
about the drivers of the Obesity problem
in poor nutrition in general we have to
think not only domestically but what's
happening around the world and given how
difficult it is to regulate Marketing in
the US there are opportunities to do
things outside the US that will provide
a database for what why it might be
important to do things here um you talk
about what's going on around the company
around the the world with uh food
nutrition issues we see lots of
exploitation food companies are doing
precisely what the tobacco companies did
uh they knew tobacco companies knew they
were going to get hammered in the United
States it was going to hurt business a
lot so all their profits were going to
come from the developing world uh you
see um things like this going on where
the food companies are crowing about
their um success in Emerging Markets
which of course is a euphemism for the
developing world and so so practices
that may may at some point be curtailed
in the US are likely to flourish in the
rest of the world so we have to keep an
eye not only on our country but what
happens elsewhere I don't think it's too
harsh to say that we live in a toxic
food environment and then marketing is a
very important part of that um when I
was at the red Center that Abby was kind
enough to mention um we did an awful lot
of work on food marketing and the group
there is still working hard on issues of
food marketing and if you go to the red
Center website
that you see down there on the bottom of
the slide they have an awful lot of
information that provides the scientific
base that documents who's being marketed
who how much marketing is occurring and
what impact it's having um any of you
who have paid attention to marketing
from a business point of view will have
heard of the the four Ps um this is the
language that the marketing World Ed to
talk talk about how how you can more
effectively Market by paying attention
to these issues but I think there could
be four impact PS of of marketing and it
would be these things it's certainly
powerful it has a a very important
effect on people's behavior of course
the companies wouldn't spend so much
money doing it it's quite persuasive um
the companies will dispute how exactly
persuasive it is but research shows that
it is it's pernicious in the sense that
it doesn't endr run around people's
cognitive abilities and this is
especially true for children and in the
case of children I think it's completely
predatory and unless something is done
about this pernicious Force it's hard to
imagine we will be able to effectively
address problems like obesity in the
United States uh here's an example of
the extent of this the Robert Wood
Johnson Foundation now is by far the
world's largest funer of work on
childhood obesity devoting a100 million
a year to the problem this has been an
absolute godsend to those of us who care
about this problem but let's compare
that to how much money the food industry
spends marketing unhealthy food to
children so so this dot that you see
entering in the screen is going to
circle around the calendar and land on
the day of the year by which the food
industry has already spent aund million
marketing just junk food just to our
children and it turns out to be January
4th so you can get a sense of the
overwhelming nature of this even if it's
even if it's not terribly effective the
sheer amount of it is is overwhelming
the ability of public Health efforts to
address the Obesity Problem by the way I
hope you appreciate how that dot circled
around the screen it took me a long time
to figure out how to do
that um so let's talk about uh marketing
of cereal so when I was at the red
Center Jennifer Harris and my other
colleagues there did a series of studies
on the marketing of breakfast cereals to
Children then they did studies on the
marketing of fast food and the marketing
of sugared Beverages and they pretty
much showed the same thing and released
a series of reports that are readily
attainable on the web in this case
called cereal
facts if we think of the marketing of of
cereal to children and again this would
apply to fast food and sugared beverages
as well and many other things we can
look at how much marketing there's done
of healthy choices versus unhealthy
choices and fancy creating a list that
rank orders in this case cereals um
according to nutrition score with the
healthiest cereals at the top and the
least healthy ones at the bottom the one
at the bottom would have the least fiber
would have the most sugar most fat Etc
and next to that you put a list of
what's marketed mostly aggressively to
Children let's see how those two lists
coincide so if you take the best dozen
cereals by nutrition score we used a a
score from researchers at Oxford
University these are the Cals that show
up on that list and let's look to see
how much marketing is done on TV on
children's websites and on something
that the companies call adur gaming so
these are company related websites that
the kids go to and play games and if you
look at all the marketing for these the
healthiest cereals it adds up to exactly
zero all right let's look at the worst
dozen cereals Now by nutrition
scores and you'll start to see names
that you clearly
recognize and let's look to see how much
marketing there's done of these things
and all of a sudden the list gets pretty
populated pretty quickly now one would
accuse the serin industry of
intentionally trying to fatten American
children but if they were out to do that
could they do it better than
this
okay um we did this report in 2008 in
2011 at the red Center we did a
follow-up report to see whether the
companies had made progress over this
three-year period of time the companies
in the meantime had fallen all over
themselves not only the seral companies
but other companies to make
self-regulatory pledges government
doesn't need to come down on us you can
trust us we will police ourselves we
care deeply about the health and
well-being of American children and
families so let's see what happened in
2008 these were the top 10 most
aggressively marketed cereals to
Children three years later after which
these promises had been made quite
publicly so uh only one serial changed
on this list serial number nine changed
and became
this and they shifted around a little
bit on where they fell on the list but
that's really it so not not a very
impressive endorsement for industry
self-regulation so if you look at what
the food industry is doing not only have
they have they re shaped our ideas about
what products might be most desirable to
eat but fundamental Norms of eating have
been changed where we eat when we eat
Etc when I was a boy nobody ate in their
automobile uh nobody would ever have
dreamed that you would have fast food
for breakfast nobody no body would have
ever guessed that you would have that
the default serving size of a sugared
beverage would be 20 ounces rather than
the six and a half or 8 ounces it used
to be and this has been done very
systematically and the countries around
the world that are catching up to us in
obesity only have to look at us to see
what's coming to a theater near them and
it's going to be this systematic
reshaping of food Norms you see it all
over the place um the fast food
companies introduced fast food for
breakfast and now
what Taco Bell has done in the other
fast food restaurants is saying that you
should have a fourth meal and this is
the meal between dinner and breakfast so
not only they saying it's okay to eat
late at night even after midnight but
that fast food is what's acceptable to
eat so these have a fundamental impact
on people's sense of what they're eating
um and you just see it in many many ways
many of you might have seen this Pizza
Hut so guess what's baked into that
crust surrounding the pizza
pizza cheese I don't know old school how
about a hot
dog so this is amusing and terrifying at
at at the same time but it shows how the
Norms are changing and so getting
getting people to eat more is one way to
of course to increase sales so their
possible paths to to try to address this
marketing Scourge that exists uh
industry self-regulation we could talk
about a lot if we had more time but it
seems to me to have pretty much failed a
few little concessions have been made to
the Public Health Community but just
enough to get a lot of credit out there
in the the arena of public relations but
not really to make meaningful changes in
what's happening in terms of marketing
public pressure could occur but it's
very hard to imagine ever being able to
amount an effort that would affect
public opinion in the face of all those
dollars that are spent marketing to
people $100 million by January 4th so
then we get into legal and Regulatory
action the reg the uh agency Regulatory
Agencies have tried hard to address this
problem uh the FTC and David vadic could
talk about this in more detail I think
has done terrific work in getting
reports released on how much marketing
is being done and how the companies are
deploying their their marketing
resources um but much more really needs
to be done and so the question is can
legal action be helpful in this context
and in in my mind it has to be or we're
not going to help address these very
significant problems um there are
several possible approaches one could be
enforcement of existing laws and
regulations that are out there there are
some compelled speech opportunities with
labeling that that warning labels would
be an example of that uh truthful Health
claims that appear on packages uh could
be part of this but I think those are
going to have small impacts compared to
where the real big action lies and
that's in ciling the commercial speech
this is where we need your help um some
people have paid attention to this Ted's
a great example of that and others here
on the panel um but we need more we need
bright Minds paying attention to this
and it could very much help the public
health uh effort to address obesity not
only in the US and around the the the
world so I think the rationale is clear
here and it's shown on this slide that
there's clear harm to children
children's health and well-being is
being seriously affected there are
strong causal relationships that have
now been proven over over a number of
years actually showing a link between
food marketing to Children the um their
preferences for certain foods requests
they make to their parents and then
things they buy on their own when they
start to have income the companies are
exploiting developmental vulnerabilities
that children have um it's hard to blame
the companies for doing this children
are an incredibly important part of
their Market not only for what they eat
and and the amount of money they control
as children but because of the brand
preferences that develop early in life
and can last a lifetime and there are
biological vulnerabilities that are
probably being exploited as well and
that leads down an interesting Road I'd
like to to come back to those biological
vulnerabilities in just a moment but I
wanted to share with you what felt to me
like a very interesting victory in this
space and it was done um by virtue of a
collaboration between the Public Health
Community mainly our Center at Yale when
I was here and the Connecticut attorney
general and it had to do with a program
called smart choices in 2009 the food
industry released this smart choices
label on some of its food products it
came about as a consequence of the
industry essentially conferring with
itself and then coming up with nutrition
standards for foods and they said that
any standard that any food that met our
our prescribed standards then could be
given this smart choice as label there
was real concern that consumers would be
confused by this and would feel that it
was a government related symbol or that
it had some meaningful nutrition
criteria behind it but the criteria were
so self-serving that foods like this
could earn the the smart choices label
so we worked closely with uh dick
Blumenthal when he was attorney general
here on trying to do something about the
smart choices program
um he had his staff attorneys look into
this found felt that there was a legal
basis under Consumer Protection Law in
Connecticut to go after smart choices
and so he he launched an investigation
into smart choices and issued demand
letters to the the companies and to the
professional associations that had been
given or one in particular that had been
given money by the the companies in
order to administer the smart choices
program and in a six- week period some
amazing events took place right about
when the smart choices program was going
to be launched the New York Times found
out that it was going to happen and
wrote quite a critical article about
this that was the first event in
September shortly after that the
Connecticut attorney general launches an
investigation this got National
publicity because the New York Times
found out about the investigation and
made it quite clear that other state AGS
might be be behind this with a
coordinated action um the commissioner
of the Food and Drug Administration held
a public phone call then based on these
earlier events that were quite critical
of the smart choices program and in
October 23rd the smart choices program
was pulled by the industry now what was
interesting here I think wasn't so much
that the Connecticut attorney general
had a strong legal case perhaps he did
but that could have worked out over a
very long period of time well beyond the
point that the companies would have been
caring about smart choices but it was
the negative publicity that rained down
on the companies it really had a big
impact so it was the involvement of a a
very visible and important legal figure
in this space that really made a big
difference now I mentioned before
biological vulnerability so I'd like to
close with this thought this is a
picture of the cocoa leaf and in in its
natural form uh people don't abuse it or
have trouble dealing with it it's only
when it's processed into cocaine or
hyper processed into crack cocaine that
humans the the the regulatory biology
that normally serves us well goes crazy
and doesn't serve us well any longer and
so the question is are there food
equivalents of this and is there an
addictive process that may get get in
instigated here that could be
particularly Troublesome in the context
of children so when you take corn which
nobody abuses in its natural form as far
as I know um but you process it in
things like this then you get you get
big public health problems and when you
take weed and process it to this you get
problems and when you take water and you
process it into this you get problems
and so one of the interesting legal
issues is does this provide ammunition
to take legal action against the food
marketing that goes on because it's
driving children to a product that not
only harms their health because of the
nutrition quality of it but creates an
addictive process um a colleague of mine
and I edited a book on this uh bringing
together all the science on the issue of
food in addition and really quite
compelling so this might be an
interesting thing to consider in the
legal context so I I'll end where I
began we need your help um food
marketing is only one of the things
driving the Obesity problem and lots of
other nutritional maladies but it's a
big one and it's a very hard one to
tackle because of the very topic that
we're dealing with here at the
conference the First Amendment we need
bright clever people thinking about how
to deal with this and clever you know
inovative new ways and I think it could
really help us make a difference in the
Public Health Arena thank
[Applause]
you I'm not sure whether my Graphics are
going to be quite as compelling as yours
uh thanks very much to Dean post and the
organizers for inviting me here I am
going to talk a bit about the state's
use of what I call compelling imagery to
influence individual health behaviors in
two contexts tobacco and abortion both
of these campaigns have been widely
criticized uh not just on First
Amendment grounds but also on ethical
grounds the basic argument being that
the state ought not use emotions like
fear and disgust to persuade these
ethical arguments which I'll get into
briefly are grounded in theories of
autonomous decision-making and are also
based on evidence uh in science and in
some cases uh Supreme Court language so
my question is whether any of the
Constitutional standards for evaluating
compelled speech can take into account
the emotional impact of some types of
graphic imagery and my answer is yes uh
regardless of whatever test you're using
there is an opportunity to incorporate
these ethical concerns into the
Constitutional
analysis so there's been a long history
of the use of imagery and emotionally
compelling imag in the public health
context you can basically trace the
history of
American ah you can trace the history of
American Public Health by looking at
posters alone and these kinds of images
have traditionally been pretty
uncontroversial until now so first of
all we've got the 2009 family smoking
prevention and Tobacco Control Act which
led to the development of FDA
regulations requiring that 50% or more
of cigarette packaging uh include Gra
graphic imagery depicting the health
consequences of smoking now the FDA
chose nine images uh the diseased lungs
you see on the right are one of them and
it chose them precisely because of their
emotional salience it relied on evidence
that these kinds of emotional images
were more likely than other types of
persuasive speech to compel people to
change their behavior uh those of you
who smoke may know that we do not in
fact have these images and that's
because in early 2003 the Attorney
General withdrew the regulations in
response to an unfavorable uh judicial
ruling in RJ
Reynolds the second context I'd like to
talk about is abortion uh we know about
abortion informed consent laws that are
passed in a variety of States many of
these laws require Physicians to provide
patients or provide them with access to
brochures presented by the state
Departments of Health depicting the
positive and negative cont consequences
of both abortion and child birth many of
these include images just like these
this is from the Texas Department of
Health brochure uh those of you who have
been following the news probably know
that there are a number of states which
also have imposed ultrasound
requirements uh and five states adopted
laws for display and describe
requirements which require a physician
to perform an ultrasound display it to
the woman and provide a a verbal
description of what is being depicted
icted regardless of whether or not the
woman wishes to hear um these campaigns
interestingly enough compared to the
tobacco campaigns actually Target or are
argued to Target positive rather than
negative emotions so proponents of these
laws say that viewing fetal imagery will
inspire feelings of maternal bonding and
therefore persuade women to carry their
pregnancies to term both of these uh
campaigns have been widely criticized
focusing on this emotionally persuasive
component interestingly enough
criticisms come pretty much based on
whichever part of the political Spectrum
you're on uh there hasn't been a
consistent argument against emotional
persuasion uh except with respect to
these particular
circumstances so the core of the
objection to emotional persuasion and I
have an article uh that I'm working on
on this is that while the government can
and should get its message across in
order to acheve achieve its policy goals
it ought to do so more on the basis of
rational argument than emotional
persuasion and this ethical objection is
grounded in theories of decisional
autonomy um if we think about decisional
autonomy as having two components the
primary substantive decision and the
secondary meta decision so primary
substantive decision is what flavor ice
cream should I have the secondary U
metad decisional level talks about how I
make the decision what kinds of question
questions do I consider do I consider
that I'm wearing a white shirt and
chocolate will stain it do I consider
that I'm going to share my ice cream
with someone and what flavors do they
like so we've got the substantive
decision and The Meta decision and the
argument is that emotional uh and
particularly emotionally compelling
graphic appeals affect decisions at this
metad decisional level they affect how
you make decisions and this effect is
exacerbated when the state is the
speaker now so there's support for this
argument about emotional persuasion uh
from neuroscience and from behavioral
psychology about the um sort of the
unrelenting impact of images that we
absorb images without even knowing it uh
images are harder to avoid they imprint
almost instantly and they have an
unavoidable impact on future
decision-making in other contexts also
some Supreme Court language has
suggested as much and Amy Adler's work
on obscenity uh provides some good
examples of this I'd also refer you to
to uh West Virginia Barnett where the
court talked about symbols like the
American flag creating quote a shortcut
for mind to mind again there the um idea
is about the the state's Reliance on
non-rational impacts uh to have an
effect now although these arguments are
uh prominent in the ethical literature
they haven't been reflected or haven't
been reflected consistently in terms of
the Constitutional analysis uh and
that's because the parties are arguing
on compelled speech grounds which as the
previous panel mentioned uh when we talk
about speech restrictions we're talking
more about the uh effect on the speaker
rather than the
listener now in the lawsuits that have
resulted in substantive decisions uh in
the tobacco and ultrasound context
courts have varied in the level of
scrutiny that I've applied and I'm not
taking a stand as to which is the
appropriate one but I am going to
demonstrate that regardless of the level
of scrutiny you use there is an
opportunity to include arguments about
emotional
persuasion so first narrow tailoring uh
both the Central Hudson test and strict
scrutiny which has been applied to some
of the abortion ultrasound cases um ask
about the tailoring of the government's
speech mandate to the ultimate goals
Central Hudson does it directly Advance
the government interest in the least
extensive way possible strict scrutiny
whether uh the speech mandate is
narrowly tailored and under both of
these tests you can consider whether
other means of communication might uh uh
might be better in terms of not running
a foul of this objection so in Discount
Tobacco uh The Descent claimed that and
of course the majority rejected this but
claimed that the uh tobacco images were
not reasonably tailored because they
attempted to flagrantly manipulate the
emotions of consumers likewise in one of
the abortion ultrasound cases uh the
court recognized the risk of
psychological harm from delivery of a
message in an emotional way and
suggested that there might be a
different mode of delivery that would be
less
harmful another opportunity to bring uh
in concerns about emotional persuasion
into the Constitutional analysis is the
question of truthfulness and whether
something is misleading whether
something is controversial uh the Zer
test asks whether the information being
conveyed is purely factual and
uncontroversial Central Hudson wants the
test to be true and not misleading and
the same goes for this Casey standard in
the ultrasound cases uh so we might want
to consider whether emotional uh graphic
images count as truthful and not
misleading and this is something that
the previous panel discussed
briefly uh in RJ Reynolds the decision
uh opposing the fda's regulations the
court did find this and found that the
inflammatory nature of these graphic
appeals uh meant that they didn't impart
purely factual and uncontroversial
information uh Discount Tobacco the six
circuit rejected this but again The
Descent uh relied on this flagrant
manipulation and said that means uh
you're manipulating not on the basis of
facts on the abortion side uh you can
also take a cue from uh some of the
conversation between the fifth circuit
and judge Sparks of the Western District
of Texas the fifth circuit said that the
ultrasound images displayed to women are
truthful and not misleading uh and the
uh judge Sparks of the Western District
of Texas responded in a pretty sharply
worded opinion saying an extended
presentation consisting of graphic
images of aborted fetuses and heartfelt
testimonials about the horrors of
abortion would according to fifth
circuit's analysis be truthful not
misleading and relevant um that this
also plays into the undue burden
analysis which Falls outside the scope
of First Amendment law uh the argument
being that there may be some types of
communications that despite being
truthful and not misleading might
nevertheless uh cause some sort of an
undue burden and the decision by the
Middle District of North Carolina that
came just down earlier this year in
Stuart versus Lumis recognized this
again it was talking about the
psychological harm that ultrasound
images might have on women who are
seeking abortions um and the court asked
that uh
this whether this kind of communication
might impose an undue burden even if it
were considered truthful and not
misleading then the final opportunity um
that I'd like to put forth about
incorporating these concerns into the
Constitutional analysis is under the
captive audience Doctrine not very
popular um the there is no explicit
right not to listen but the Supreme
Court has recognized that in certain
instances uh it will protect unwilling
listeners from messages that are
communicated in ways that make them hard
to avoid so we hear we have sounds of
protesters outside abortion clinics uh
unwanted and unavoidable intrusions into
the home Etc now in Cohen versus
California the the draft case the
court said well people who are offended
can simply observe uh avert their eyes
they don't have to look at the jacket
that says the draft uh but again
Recent research uh in uh neuroscience
and behavioral psychology demonstrates
that that might not actually be possible
in order to recognize that you're
offended by an image you have to see it
it'll imprint on your brain and perhaps
uh the Court's suggestion that well you
can simply avoid an image that you don't
want to see is unrealistic especially
when for example in the tobacco context
50% or more of tobacco packaging is
covered in these
images so um the legal system is very
often a flawed way of a flawed mechanism
for resolving or even addressing
controversial ethical issues but I think
this one particular area where we have
States involvement in compelling speech
in order to persuade people to adopt
healthy behaviors this is one
opportunity where we can in fact bring
ethical arguments into the
Constitutional analysis um moreover the
fact is that many of these arguments are
supported by scientific evidence uh and
that might offer opportunities for
considering these types of cases in the
future thanks very
[Applause]
much since we're talking about Behavior
we have Christine jeles who has come
just in the nick of time and Christine
do you need a PowerPoint loaded or
anything yeah I could just do first
you've been introduced already
so did I just just unplug the
changer okay it's ready to use so
I
all right uh well I have to start of
course by making a very heartfelt
apology for my late arrival uh my uh two
high schoolers parents weekend up in
Boston where we live is uh today and
tomorrow so I'm kind of trying to divide
my time between Boston and New Haven and
there was a big accident on 91 I thought
I was doing great I I emailed Abby that
things looked good and then all of a
sudden we stopped so I I know it's
disruptive and I really sincerely
apologize um also just one other
preliminary uh I really want to thank
the conference organizers especially
Professor kinsky for the great schedule
and the Fantastic materials that were
put together um we've all been looking
forward to this conference for a while
uh so as Abby suggests Professor GL
suggested I'm sort of uh partially here
in my role as a someone who's very
interested in behavioral economics and
empirical uh analysis and that's what
I'd like to uh spend a couple of moments
speaking with you about um law of course
in in many different ways is concerned
with the availability and allocation of
information uh and we're all very
familiar with mandated information
disclosures or Warnings on uh tobacco
packages food packages and other uh
other uh products and in significant
part at least what these Target is
factually erroneous perceptions among
consumers um uh of course these mandates
may have other goals as well uh but
reducing factually erroneous perceptions
is a uh readily accepted goal under the
First Amendment and of course as uh was
just being discussed a big question is
well what what does it mean to reduce uh
people's misperceptions or what what is
truthful information and what I'd like
to uh do in our time uh in the next few
minutes is describe some empirical
evidence that behavioral economics and
adjacent disciplines have tried to
develop to address this question instead
of in a kind of a priori way um instead
in a in a more thoroughgoing empirical
way uh I'm specifically going to focus
and this kind of grows out of uh the
tobacco uh example that's already been
discussed on the role of pictorial
material uh in mandated
disclosures um there is some language in
some of the tobacco Court decisions
suggesting and this is a familiar idea
in other areas of law as well that
pictures are sort of uh more dangerous
from a first amend perspective maybe
they play with our emotions they're not
rational uh you know several of my
colleagues here I've had lengthy
discussions about well you know if you
if you're if you are making a statement
in words you are reasoning with someone
and if you're um uh presenting material
in a non-textual format that that
somehow raises suspicions that uh that
were not reasoning or or uh and of
course the tobacco images because
they're so uh arresting make this even
more uh of a concern um so what I want
to do is kind of um I'll reference some
empirical work I did on the tobacco
disclosures at the end but I wanted to
sort of normalize this by looking at a
bunch of other forms of pictorial
material in Legally mandated disclosures
and look at what we know about the
effects of that on people's uh the
accuracy of people's factual um uh
perceptions uh I'm going to mostly talk
about nutrition labeling today I
definitely am not an expert in the field
as are uh other people in this room and
on this panel uh so I um would love any
you know follow-ups or uh additions to
the material I'm about to describe uh
but a number of countries around the
world have experimented recently with
mandating uh in addition or instead of
the detailed nutrition facts label that
we're familiar with in the states uh a
kind of pictorial representation of the
health components or unhealth un
healthfulness components of a food um
this is called the nutrition star that
is on this slide and I'm going to focus
on a a
a a uh thing that is commonly referred
to as uh nutrition traffic light
labeling um and I focus on that because
of the great empirical evidence that's
available on uh people's factual
perceptions under this kind of um
pictorial
element so obviously red is means uh the
food is bad on it the dimension and
green means the food is good on on the
dimension in
question uh this uh to my knowledge was
originally developed in in a great depth
in the UK uh has uh also been legally
mandated in other countries U most
recently Ecuador uh my understanding is
that it's used kind of in a voluntary
arrangement in the UK uh but the UK has
done a lot of work on this and has a
tremendous amount of empirical evidence
that I uh draw on so we have a large
sample almost 3,000 uh UK adults who are
people responsible for grocery shopping
and a very tight set of studies that
randomly assign people to either view
the label uh that you just saw with the
traffic light
coloring or an otherwise completely
identical label same numbers same
dimensions same everything but just no
red green or or Amber and uh I I'm
interested in these kind kind of tight
tests because they really go to they
they very precisely allow us to look at
uh is there an informational component
of non-text material on a disclosure so
holding exactly the same the words and
numbers and how their placement and how
big the font is and all of that if we
add a pictorial element like a star or
nutrition labeling um and there are lots
of other examples I I've been working on
in in an article that I'm almost done
drafting uh what do we know about how
that that one change in this controlled
environment affects people's factual
perceptions about the item in question
uh so in this study uh we have people
randomly assigned to see uh one type of
label or the other type of label and
I'll show you two different results
slides because uh they the study authors
looked at both snack siiz versions of
food and U meal-sized
products um
now an economist and and perhaps a
non-economist might uh be sort of
suspicious of how what what do you mean
when people are ranking healthfulness of
products um and the approach taken in
this study is to have expert
nutritionists uh evaluate products
healthfulness and then we compare the
the rankings that respondents in the
study who are these everyday Shoppers
give to these expert nutritionists and
the closer they are to accuracy in the
health of a particular product uh the
the the better off we conclude they are
in terms of their level of factual
informedness um I
myself probably because of being trained
as an economist am a little suspicious
of what we can learn from the absolute
level of these ratings uh but that's not
what I'm interested in so what I all I
want to look at is the comparison
between on the one hand people who see
the set of numbers with the traffic
light coloring and on the other hand and
the different people randomly chosen who
see that exact same thing in black and
white and whether or not I'm thrilled
with the measure of how uh accurately
they're informed about the healthfulness
I I certainly feel confident that I see
a difference between those two and I see
the traffic light folks uh doing
significantly better uh I I feel
confident that we're learning something
regardless of whether uh we're confident
in in every aspect of that
measure uh so here are the results of
this study uh for the snack-sized
portion of the food item um the
respondents uh matched the expert
healthfulness ratings 65% of the time
with the traffic light label compared to
56% without and that's a statistically
significant difference um again the only
difference in the material these folks
saw was a non-textual kind of pictorial
element in the form of the coloring on
the slide uh the the direction uh
difference was in the same direction for
the meal size port portion uh although
not as large and not not statistically
significant uh but in the same direction
and very similar results uh with the um
uh a second measure of healthfulness so
in these results on this slide people
were asked not about the overall
healthfulness of the product but the
healthfulness in regard to a
particular uh nutrient aspect such as
fat or salt uh and very similar to
before the snack size portion uh both
the snack size portion and the meal siiz
portion we see more correct answers with
the addition of the traffic light
labeling than without uh and we see that
to a greater degree and to a
statistically significant degree for the
snack size uh
portion uh these results are very
similar to uh some other results that I
present in the um current article that
I'm I'm working on and also in some
already published results that I thought
I would mention briefly here because I
knew others on the panel would be
talking about the tobacco warnings uh so
as you as have already been uh as has
already been discussed uh the FDA uh
attempted to mandate uh warnings about
cigarette uh risks that were accompanied
by photos um I've chosen one example
here because this is one of the ones
that performs the best on the empirical
measures I'm looking at which concern
people's factual accuracy about smoking
risks uh so this study is
methodologically very similar to the UK
food labeling study you have about 3,000
respondents um who are uh uh
stakeholders in the so in the UK study
we have people who actually are
responsible for grocery shopping their
family the study you have people who are
smokers uh and half of them receive uh a
warning like what you see up here with a
picture and the other half receive just
the textual statement warning tobacco
smoke can harm your
children now again uh a lot of the First
Amendment litigation on this uh type of
material focused on um the the um
potentially manipulative or uh emotional
aspects of These Warnings which are
undeniable uh but what I want to do is
just join that conversation with an
additional data point which is that
These Warnings also make people more
factually accurate in answering right
and wrong questions so in a sense people
are more likely to say 2 plus 2 is four
uh if they see the warning with the
picture than if they see just the text
um the specific question there's a
number of measures that I use but this
is the one that I like the best uh uh
question asks respondents uh to express
their level of agreement with the
following statement if I smoked a pack
of cigarettes a day for more than 20
years there is little health benefit to
me quitting smoking um now to the best
of my understanding uh nobody who works
on health and smoking thinks that's a
correct statement so so agreeing with
that uh is is is something that we're
we're happy to say is making some kind
of factual error and in fact uh there's
a significantly uh different and lower
level of agreement with that statement
from people who see the picture and the
text uh that I showed earlier than from
people who just see the the bottom two
lines warning tobacco smoke can harm
your children um there are a few other
measures in my uh 2013 article that also
point in the same direction other
measures that don't get to is this
upsetting is this disgusting should I
quit smoking no they say uh they they
ask you factual questions uh and we see
how people answer those factual
questions and we find time and time
again that there is an uptick and
accuracy in answering these questions
when people have received uh a pictorial
warning as opposed to a text only
warning um uh so in conclusion um I
think this evidence from um social
science uh behavioral economics and
other fields in social science allows us
to consider uh alongside the other
factors that we're going to be exploring
and have already started exploring at
this conference uh the perhaps slightly
less heated but but important question
of how different forms of
disclosure affect people's uh factual
perceptions um and although we won't
always have good empirical evidence on
those questions and we may need to have
uh the kind of judicial speculation uh
that we see in some of these opinions
about whether these uh these uh
Communications are informing people or
terrorizing people um my vote is instead
of a intelligent but
ultimately uh untested speculation about
those things let's go to the data and if
we can find that a set of warnings that
have a pictorial component a non-textual
component that doesn't have any you know
rational uh uh aspect to it if we find
that people are more likely to correctly
say 2 plus 2 is four with that uh
communication then with the words only
of that communication and not the
pictorial element that's something that
deserves some weight in the First
Amendment uh balance that we're doing in
the in a context like the Zer uh or
Central Hudson commercial speech test um
thank you again for your attention and I
again I I really uh give my most sincere
and mortified apology for walking in so
late Christine maybe if you put a
picture of your apology on the screen it
would have been more
effective since I didn't know it would
be necessary until about 40 minutes ago
I could prepared okay we'll go to Ted
now for our final
presentation all right uh I am Ted
merman uh thank you Abby I actually um
developed the habit of filing amikas
briefs at the California Attorney
General's office it's a habit I have not
yet broken uh and I have filed amas
briefs in fact in many of the cases that
have been mentioned that are in the
packet uh on behalf of some of the
organizations that are in this room um
some of if you don't recognize Ted
merman some of them were filed under my
num dear Seth e merman I am not however
Jonathan merman uh who in the New York
Times yesterday called Tom freeden a
honey
badger I proud to say that is my brother
who runs HIV and AIDS policy for the
Centers for Disease Control and is just
back from doing the same thing for Ebola
in Sierra
Leon uh the title of this uh talk with
apologies to Daniel Conan is on the
screen uh another potential title is
government by wishful
thinking uh the connection that we're
we're looking to establish or I'm
looking to establish here is between uh
these guys uh those guys and
this we
begin with the Apparently small but
troubling misalignment between uh the
stated commercial speech Doctrine and
the ability of certain audience members
uh the commercial speech Doctrine posits
intelligent and well-informed purchasing
decisions that's Virginia pharmacy any
of you who have ever had young children
will attest that although they are
endlessly and deeply brilliant their
purchasing decisions are not necess
necessarily intelligent and
well-informed cognitive research uh
indicates that young children cannot
effectively recognize the persuasive
intent of advertising or apply the
critical evaluation required to
comprehend commercial messages the First
Amendment does not protect and this is I
think something that came up in the last
panel it's an important adverb uh
inherently misleading commercial speech
or actually misleading commercial speech
uh that's what falls out under the first
prong of Central Hudson the
determination whether an advertisement
is misleading requires consideration of
the legal sophistication of its audience
that's the Bates case that judge
kazinski ma uh mentioned given this
combination that government can prohibit
inherently misleading advertising and
that children cannot adequately
understand and act upon commercial
messages advertising to children younger
than age 12 about should be considered
beyond the scope of constitutional
protection
that's
moderately uh
uncontroversial much more
uncontroversial there's Recent research
on adolescence Kelly and some of his
colleagues have have been involved in
this showing that they are a species uh
with great impulsiveness uh great
vulnerability to ads focused on uh
identity peer groups uh so science is
actually therefore rather dubious even
about older children's ability to detect
and process an act in response to
advertising in a rational way now if I
may digress momentarily I don't know if
you can see this but I'll read it we
have traveled uh far perhaps irrevocably
far from the original basis for first
amendment protection for commercial
speech and if you don't believe me talk
to David vadic it's his fault uh very it
it's very difficult to recognize I think
now the rationale of conveying
information to listeners in recent cases
extoling the and the virtues of
Corporations as speakers uh but this
scenario should not perhaps have come as
a surprise what we have up here is uh
from uh a the the files of Justice
Powell this is the bench
memorandum uh by from the law clerk who
drafted the majority opinion in Central
Hudson it states the motivating
principle of the Court's recent
commercial speech cases that commercial
information must be as widely
disseminated as possible could probably
be derived from Mr Herbert Spencer's
social Statics to paraphrase homes in
lockner I am dubious that the court can
be deterred from pursuing these ideas
but I am also dubious that it will end
well this Clerk David in the heading had
a pretty clear view down the road as it
turns out but the
court for some reason has not adopted
the principle that the proper view of
the first amendment is not the market
place of ideas or self-governance or the
checking of government power or the
letting off of steam or even self-
fulfillment but instead a guarantor of
the current American economic system
that would make sense to put it in more
formal terms a way of making sure that
more people buy more stuff that doctrine
that theory would explain what we've
seen going on I would posit that what we
otherwise see does not but unless and
until we get to that point we are left
with a const constitutional provision
where ideology is heading in One
Direction and reality remains in a very
different
place now back to where we were I
believe we were talking about them uh
research and case law converge around
the idea that government could restrict
speech and even compel emotion evoking
disclosures perhaps where the target
audience is made up primarily of
children under 12 young children
certainly Congress could probably bar
for example some of the things that
Kelly men mentioned all online junk food
adver games aimed at these young
children the FCC could probably cap the
number of junk food advertisements on
children's television programs the FTC
could constitutionally restrict the use
of licensed characters and ads directed
to young children what about older
children as I said the research on
adolescence is compelling but the case
law is going in the other direction uh
one non-commercial speech case that that
was handed down recently by the Supreme
Court Brown versus entertainment
Merchants Association the violent video
games case the Court held that uh said
children it meant older children have
considerable First Amendment rights uh
and even chief justice Roberts and
Justice Alo
concurring said they they opined that
perhaps young children could be treated
differently but they were not willing to
provide that sort of paternalism I
suppose towards
adolescence so we have a situation where
there is not much room to operate
government could probably go right ahead
and ban all tobacco advertising in
elementary schools even though remember
they have teachers they have adults who
are entitled to you know receive
truthful Anonymous leading information
about legal products but as soon as we
get beyond the areas that are limited to
children or in the case of tobacco
advertising limited to minors government
has a problem when some unspecified
percentage of adults are in the audience
uh suddenly you are out from under that
first prong of Central Hudson uh and the
government is stuck because the
restrictions not narrowly tailored
enough to pass even the rest of Central
Hudson uh so we don't even have to
decide if strict scrutiny should really
apply in these commercial speech cases
that by the way is the this is the
tragedy of the indecision don't think
that this you know the commercial speech
Doctrine or the commercial speech test
of Central Hudson is in any way uh uh
formed fully uh for two decades we have
had uh the test of heightened scrutiny
this is not new from cell there's more
there's new stuff in cell but heighten
scrutiny is not new uh for 20 years the
court has not decided whether Central
Hudson applies to restrictions on
Commercial speech it said maybe it's
Central Hudson maybe it's strict
scrutiny but it fails under even the
more lenient test of Central Hudson and
what that does of course is it means
that the court has to knock down every
single restriction it takes on and
reviews because if it didn't it would
have to
decide so can we agree that we have a
bit of a problem problem here I think
what we've heard from Kelly about the
size of the issue is compelling uh we
have heard from Nadia and Christine
about some of the uh thinking that might
go into the response that Kelly has
called for there's a disparity we have
been fighting a rear guard action that
is for sure and I think we've been doing
it for too long we are probably not
going to be able to get done what Kelly
says we need to do about even food
marketing to children because the number
one show among young children in the
last decade for example was not
SpongeBob it was not Dora the Explorer
it was that and there are I believe
adults who also watched that
show to update the the dictum from
Butler we may not reduce the cable box
to that which is appropriate of the
sandbox so maybe we should just do what
we can and eliminate advertising on
shows and in media dedicated just to
kids well the FTC tried that 35 years
ago it didn't go so well though the
First Amendment didn't stand in the way
of the the the program called kid vid
something else did there was a massive
massive lobbying effort that effectively
shut down the FTC temporarily kept it in
abeyance for a decade we fast forward
for 30 years and this was in the packet
of conference materials Congress asks
for a study by an inter agency working
group to look at nutritional standards
for food marketing to Children it would
just be advisory asked to chair the
effort the FTC you can imagine how the
FTC felt about this and you probably see
where this is going they issued on
behalf of the FDC the Department of
Agriculture CDC and the FDA a draft
report for comment those draft
guidelines then were in turn challenged
on First Amendment grounds even though
they were just guidelines and then the
big guns the lobbyist it turns out well
they don't just use courts they use
Congress they use the White House they
uh they uh go and chat on a constant
basis with the agencies themselves that
report was never finalized this was not
however a First Amendment problem unless
you consider for some reason the
influence excuse me for some reason the
influence of lobbying and corporate
money on politics to be a problem which
of course as we know it is
not
so the First Amendment walls have closed
in pretty tightly on public health
officials and legislators we can try to
play with the limited room we have but
at the same time I think we need to look
at ways to get a little more space to
operate to push against and maybe uh
make some holes in these walls how well
there's much on the agenda at this
conference about science we have heard
about the importance of scientific
research in either establishing what
government can and should require
manufacturers to say and in determining
what advertisers cannot say if they
can't substantiate their claims for
example the iant caffeine impregnated
anticellulite
shapewear does not as it turns out
actually help you lose weight nor and I
know I'm going to disappoint you David
mentioned this earlier will pouring
Sensa powder onto your food at each meal
do the trick so let's look at another
way that science may be able to help in
similar fashion by debunking myths what
happens when we look with some amount of
scientific rigor or perhaps simply uh
impartial skepticism at the myths that
we and our
courts all courts but one uh live
by we know that children can't
understand and effectively discount
advertising claims apparently though
significant sads of the American public
anyone who purchased the eye pant can't
either the problem does not end there
right Daniel Conan and Cass sunstein
Richard Taylor have established I would
say pretty convincingly that Chicago
School economic theory doesn't do a very
good job of describing how humans as
opposed to the old ways rational econs
actually
behave all right so maybe we need some
disclosures to help clean up the
potential deceptiveness but no omry Ben
Shahar Carl Schneider Lauren Willis and
uh I would say Aaron kesselheim have
shown us again pretty convincingly that
most dis closures simply do not work if
by working we mean conveying factual
information to a reasonable consumer for
purposes of making utility maximizing
decisions in the marketplace or if by
working we mean people read them because
neither one is the case and yet as a
society as a legal system we rely on
them defendants and courts welcome
disclosures as a superior option to
restrictions on speech because they add
more information to the scream of
Commerce
but humans do not read them and I would
add uh econs who as Conan says know how
to deal with the small print when it
matters don't actually exist the emperor
not only has no clothes he doesn't
actually exist so let's return to the
law we have a system that is acting on a
view of people as rational actors we'll
call them
lexon which in when in fact people are
flawed and not very sharp humans the
system is protecting the wrong people
what is going on there seems to be an
ill match a lack of reasonable fit if
you will
between the beings that the commercial
speech Doctrine posits and acts upon
lexon and the actual humans who populate
this Society there they are here's an
interesting thing this is not unique to
the First Amendment it runs throughout
the law and particularly throughout the
law of Public Health take for example
the story of HIV pre uh prevention
policy in this country story of a
government acting to respond to a
population of idealized people who did
not then and have not since ever existed
how many years was it before the federal
government was willing to promote a
prevention practice Beyond monogamy or
even better abstinence not until 5 years
ago did the federal government permit
funding of needle exchange programs for
IV drug users and two years after that
it changed its mind why because the
ideal person in a high-risk group was
strictly a victim a hoph act kid who had
to get blood products it was not someone
who used IV drugs it was not someone who
had multiple partners and goodness knows
it was not someone who had sex without a
condom but the problem is real people
did those things you know the old joke
about the person who looks for her watch
on the street where uh you know a block
over from where she lost it because the
light is better
there that's what the government's doing
we're doing our duty we're providing
these Public Health Services we don't
care if it doesn't help you it's your
fault don't talk to me so what do we do
what what can help how about and here
Kelly I call upon you reality in the
form of science or empirical
evidence Kelly says that you you need
law lawyers we say back to you we need
science we need so studies showing the
impact of condom use at least under
ideal conditions in preventing
transmission had an enormous impact in
making uh in in changing government
guidelines just this summer The CDC
issued a remarkable announcement in
light of study showing that Truvada a
combination of antiviral drugs
significantly reduced transmission among
gay men who took it pre-exposure the US
government effectively gave the green
light to the use of a drug that may
increase casual sex its users are known
affectionately as truat hores and
generally shatter whatever remains of
the ideal image of a well-behaved person
at risk of HIV infection in favor of a
policy that responds to what people
humans are actually doing and tries to
save their lives
how can it be how did that happen it can
be because scientific studies showed
that incidents of infection dropped by
between 50 and 90% for those taking
Truvada the science speaks for itself
well it turns out that the landscape and
I'll be brief uh where government and
public health meet is dotted by
illustrations of the idealized human
real human dilemma uh for those of you
who at any time in your lives have lived
in New York City this may be a familiar
uh image decades ago it was common on
hot days in summer to see people in land
in landlocked Urban neighborhoods
playing in the streets in the wild flow
of a totally open fire hydrant the city
fought these vandals it turned off the
hydrants it installed safety locks it
Arrested people none of those measures
worked and then someone had the Nutty
idea of actually looking at why people
were opening the hydrant it turned out
they were
hot the openings happened during heat
waves where without in in neighborhoods
without pools or Park sprinklers are
even backyard so the someone who stopped
to figure out why people were risking
fines and their freedom to open hydrant
said what if we distributed spray
caps the dangerous diversion of water
flowed water flow dropped from a th000
gallons a minute to 25 the kids could
cool off everyone was happy it's the end
of the story it is not the government
was not happy people were not behaving
correctly there was still 25 gallons a
minute being poured into the street so a
number of years later during the Jew
iani Administration when the city
discovered new types of locks that it
thought could keep civilians from
turning on the hydrants it installed
them and the fire chief said and I quote
fire hydrant should be for firefighting
not for
playing it is very difficult for the
government to let go of the idea that
people should act and must act and do
act as morality and good judgment and
the law expect them to and of course uh
those locks even the new ones were soon
picked so it seems that science and even
to follow the Supreme Court and Laurel
art Common Sense can go a long way
towards breaking down uh the ideals
these ill-fitting ideals if Government
can show that disclosures don't work in
their current form that should maybe
cause us to look at what the disclosures
consist of maybe they should in fact
involve emotion after all what is the
point deep down of an ineffective
disclosure it may assuage our Collective
conscience it does not in itself prevent
what could be serious harm or
death uh what about restrictions on
speech if evidence showed that a
particular ad technique was manipulative
designed to evade the rational mind then
the first amendment should not protect
it yet consider the state of advertising
today as Kelly mentioned we have
immersive advertising behavioral
targeting product placement and of
course
neuromarketing we measure realtime
responses at both the conscious and
subconscious levels these are companies
that work with advertisers to hook up
kids
uh and uh adults to electrodes they they
use the neurom marketing to hack your
brain uh and I would say uh create
something other than sort of the
rational uh uh conveyance of ideas for
use in decision- making are there limit
limits to this reality check and this is
my last slide I promise there are we
need ideals there are is stuff that as a
society we want to keep even though it
may not align well with empirical
evidence uh I don't know if all people
are in fact created equal but uh we do
need I think uh there are other ideals
that we might question uh the equality
of uh speakers in the marketplace is one
the marketplace of ideas is not the idea
of the marketplace to paraphrase David
the clerk we could adopt that principle
but I don't think it would end well in
some we are faced with a serious
misalignment between the founding goals
of a commercial speech Doctrine
information for provision driving
rational consumer Behavior and the
reality of a 21st century World
permeated by image advertising adver
games disclosures by the ream a plethora
of other techniques designed precisely
to avoid the purpose for which
Constitutional protection was provided
to commercial speech in the first place
enough already with the ideal is time to
get
real um that was a a really interesting
and diverse array of presentations uh I
can ask the first question when people
mobilize their own questions as in the
last panel you can just line up with
those microphones um I will um I first I
wanted to just make a link between uh
this panel and the last panel because it
seemed like there's a pretty interesting
link between what aarin was talking
about in the last panel the challenge of
getting doctors informed with truthful
information about off Lael drugs and in
a form that they can absorb and in some
ways there are some parallels here to G
the public informed in a similar way
just sort of an interesting link between
them um but my first question really
probably goes to Nadia and Kelly and
it's this question about over
inclusiveness um you know when we first
were planning this panel it was we were
talking about tobacco and obesity and at
around the same time I never sorted
thinking well these are really good
Market marketing campains for public
health and at the time the ultrasound
laws stuff was happening we were
thinking well what if you throw the
ultrasound laws into the mix and thenly
things get very complicated right you
get an over inclusiveness problem and
then Kelly's AR ument is really about
taking an analogy in some ways from
tobacco to food but tobacco is just one
plant right and the lines you presented
to us include everything up to water
right could be uh thrown into this
bucket and so I guess the question for
you two is um how's how course going to
draw the line and is the problem of over
inclusiveness um going to hamper all of
these kinds of conversations in a way
that makes them
intractable you know
that's that is a hard question um
you know in drawing a link between the
tobacco and the ultrasound laws my
intent at least was to demonstrate that
the same concerns apply to both and that
if there's a reason to treat them
differently uh as I'd suggest many sort
of in the liberal sphere would think
those reasons need to be identified uh
and that's something that I don't think
has been done yet and I think the same
would play out if you're comparing
tobacco labor and food marketing right
uh or or certain types of food marketing
where you draw that line is going to
require some kind of justifiable
reasoning and maybe that's going to come
from empirical evidence demonstrating
okay certain uh certain kinds of
interventions can actually be effective
in um making people more attuned to the
truth and recognizing truthful facts
some don't but I don't think that we can
draw that line just on the basis of you
know political preference
or on intuitions about what we think is
appropriate or
not and I I don't know that I have a
good answer to your question because
it's a legal one I think essentially but
my guess is that it that if Common Sense
prevails here you look at the nature of
a problem and how much harm is being
done and at some point the harm gets to
a level high enough that some level of
inclusiveness is probably warranted and
the question is in the issues we're
talking about like food marketing to
children have we crossed that threshold
I think we clearly have heart disease
cancer stroke diabetes all those things
are being driven in part at least by the
marketing practices and so I think
there's probably some level that's been
crossed and it justifies more action
than might what might be done
otherwise um I this sounds a little uh
this is kind of negative and it's not
the kind of argument I usually like to
be making but I I actually feel like one
urgent thing in this domain is to strike
out at bad lines you know so I don't
necessarily have to have an ideal line
to say that a First Amendment court that
writes uh pictures or or non-text
content uh is not a valid way for the
government to communicate uh even
factual information I I think that's uh
I mean if you know anything about
behavioral economics or know anything
about this empirical data that's a very
frightening possibility uh I mean
advertisers of course can use lots of
things other than text um and so I I'm
uh feel very strongly about trying to uh
normalize non-text tools in the
government hands not to say that all of
them are fine or not to say I know
exactly the line that that is okay but I
I certainly want to say that a line that
is fairly black and white yes text no
pictures uh is a bad idea you know one
example just a super quick and I don't
have empirical data on this one I just
find it fascinating is you know in the
US on alcoholic beverages we have a word
warning about not mixing um drinks and
pregnancy uh and you know when I was
pregnant which you know was a number of
years ago uh I I had a number of
different interesting experiences
including like what one experience at a
place where this guy tried to pressure
me into drinking you know like oh it's
actually okay to drink you know and uh
then I was reading in the course of
doing this research for this upcoming
article about how France has gone to a
pictogram on wine bottles uh so and it
it's a pretty arresting pictogram it
shows a you know a side profile of a
very pregnant woman uh and then it has a
red circle and a slash through it um and
uh I think that is uh I mean it's
nothing like the cigarette ads um but it
is evocative in a way that might improve
people's understanding and if so I'd be
very concerned about a court saying oh
that would violate the First Amendment
because you know it's it's it doesn't
use words so I'm into getting rid of
that bad line at
least to touch I had a question of uh
Christine
no no just a fual question I was
interested in the study you had where
you compared the message plus a picture
was just the message and um I I think
one of the reasons uh I don't get to my
question I think one of the reasons
the um messages uh with the p or the
pictures on the cigarettes wind up being
blocked is it were just so
nasty uh I think a lot of people were
just offended by them and maybe you know
the purpose was to offend but I'm
wondering uh was there any study of
showing a message with a nasty
picture versus a message with a more
neutral picture and I and my question is
whether I'm wondering whether it is not
the nasty picture
that caused people to get the message
but whether seeing a picture and using
that part of the brain that processes
pictures is what did it and and and
perhap I I just don't know what the was
that tested yeah yes so um uh there were
originally 36 images that were selected
by the FDA and uh studied extensively uh
and nine of them uh were chosen and many
of the ones that weren't chosen were
less distressing and awful than many of
the ones that were chosen um my best
understanding of why it happened that
way is that the FDA thought and this was
what the DC circuit focused on they
thought that what they should really
show is how many people would stop
smoking or say they would stop smoking
so they weren't focused on which of
these images uh made people more
factually accurate about the health
effects of smoking they were very
focused on changing people's behavior
which I think is strange because when
you're talking about the first amendment
I that makes you know me nervous and I'm
sure it makes you nervous uh but the FDA
uh in their wisdom focused on those
kinds of measures about Behavior change
and sort of emotional affect and so the
nine subset that they selected out of
the 36 did tend to be disproportionately
the very distressing ones um so for
example one that wasn't chosen uh that
did does very well on a reducing factual
uh misimpressions I think just by
getting to people to focus is the
writing of a warning in a child's
handwriting on like a a a school pad you
know those uh pads that you have with a
dotted line and so there were no there
was no photo of any sort uh but it but
it was it did capture the attention and
it had an evocative aspect um so yes I
think there are ways to to do cigarette
warnings and other things that are are
uh well well more restrained than what
what the FDA ended up CH youve some or
most of the same results well again it's
dep you know so the the data available
spans a lot of different outcomes and
the government was more focused on
outcomes that were like how horrifying
do you find these images how do you feel
nauseous thinking about smoking a
cigarette after seeing these pictures so
of course if you're going for the ones
that do well on that you're going to end
up with the ones that we were discussing
uh but they had a lot of questions in
their data and did almost nothing with
it that were more about the factual
aspects of smoking and different um
warnings did better uh on those um
measures and I wanted to say one more
sentence um hopefully it'll come back to
me later just to clarify in term you
said different uh different warnings
were more effective on uh reducing
erroneous information you're saying
different warnings than the nine that
were selected out of the
36 yes the uh some of the other 27
photos each each text there were nine
textual statements as you know and then
each of them was tested between three
and seven P picture
accompaniment um thank you this is
fascinating and I I I guess I see
another length between maybe related to
the one Abby was talking about between
this conference this this panel and the
last one and that part of the direction
that say Christine your work is going in
maybe na your work too would be like
evaluating very intensively empirically
what a message means and what effect it
will have before the government could do
it and that seems to me to link up to
some of the things we were talking about
on the last panel which is to say sort
of who Bears the burden of What kinds of
proof and what will happen if we move to
an a regulatory environment where you
have lots of proof demanded um so I
guess I'm just curious um how you all
react to the idea of in some sense the
burden of proof and how much governments
should have to spend to be able to
decide okay we and does it have to be
all Case by case or could this be
adjudicated in some other way I guess um
in part Christine I was also really
interested in the data you presented I
mean I wonder did you this goes to the
bigness of the empirical problem because
I could imagine that there would be ways
in which an image might better inform
people on one metric and then disinform
them on another so let me just like
pause it that maybe people overestimate
the risk that they'll die of lung cancer
and so maybe an image will make them
more aware that if they quit smoking
they'll be better likely to but they
actually become too likely to think that
they'll die of lung cancer right so how
do you know when you've asked enough
questions about the right you know like
like which facts are even implicated by
some of these images that just seems to
me imp so I'm curious what you think
about that empirically um and I guess um
Nadia I wanted to ask you because
there's obviously some tension between
some some of the ways that that you're
thinking about maybe you could parse
what you and Christine are doing and
sort of say they're all consistent
because it's about are you mobilizing
disgust or are you going to just be
thinking about information and use P
pictures but guess there might also be
other ways to defend or to think about
the First Amendment um the ultrasound
cases we'll maybe talk about some of
this tomorrow but you know I mean are
you sympathetic to the idea or do you
think it just doesn't work that for
example the doctors ought to have First
Amendment rights not to do not to say be
involved in the showing of these
ultrasounds because this isn't the
practice of medicine this these are not
ultrasounds that are medically indicated
you know are there other ways within a
First Amendment context to get at the
question other than the kind of
discussed
rationale um so I originally I was
worried that that we would be deeply
inconsistent but I'm actually completely
fascinated by your research and I
support the idea that empirical evidence
can help us better get at what is an
appropriate emotional or graphic appeal
I'm by no means saying that they're
absolutely wrong that they should be
prohibited I think that there are
characteristics of graphic graphical and
emotional appeals that are more
troubling so for example particularly in
situations where they are unavoidable
and this goes to the captive audience
Doctrine right a woman is in a doctor's
office she the ultrasound is being
displayed and described to her she's
permitted to not look at it and not
listen to it some doctor's offices have
headphones so that women don't have to
listen to it right that kind of
communication that is unavoidable I
think is problematic um I also think
perhaps the closer in time that this
kind of verbal visual or graphic
communication comes to the
decision-making process the more those
affect-based aspects May um impact
decision-making but I think if there's
empirical evidence that visual images or
emotionally compelling images are
actually more effective at getting
people to understand scientific facts I
think that's huge I in that instance I
think that would be a great piece of
evidence to support their use um just
going back to to Ted's Point very
briefly you said well we've got we've
got science that we can say these kinds
of uh this is this is appropriate but
congressmen aren't rational actors
either and if you pres present them with
scientific facts it's it's unclear that
they'll necessarily be swayed by
it um the question of how much evidence
we should require is you know kind of a
pervasively insistent question that
anyone who talks about the connection
between empirical evidence and legal
policy is always faced with and it um I
mean it's it's kind of as soon as you
state it like that you realize it's a
very difficult question to answer um I
think we are so far from the the
whatever the ending point should be that
you know what it's easy to for me to say
the direction we should move in which is
from almost no consideration of this
kind of evidence to some consideration
of it and if we reconvene here in 10
years and we've had this huge out ing of
empirical analysis then you know I would
love to be at a point where I had the
luxury of thinking well you know do we
how much are we are we close to the
point we should require like that would
be great if we but right now we're so
far from that that I I don't I don't
know exactly how much we should require
I just know that we are we are Miles uh
below it and just one more sentence um
you know you you referred to some of the
law professors who write on the question
of you know does disclosure work one
thing that's very frustrating about that
that debate in the legal scholarship is
that uh often those interventions are
just pitched at a very high level so
like of course of course 150 page
mortgage disclosure that even you know
Richard Posner and John Roberts and
other judges tell us of course they
would never read something like that of
course that's not an effective
disclosure but there are lots of places
where we have lots of data that there
are different disclosure levers we can
pull that do affect different outcomes
and I'd rather see people um being a
little bit more uh discriminating and
you mentioned Lauren uh Professor Lauren
Willis her work work is fascinating
she's an expert in consumer Lending and
she basically goes to these different
banks and gets detailed information
about uh to support her view that in
that context mandated disclosures are
usually ineffective and basically it
turns out that all these people sit
around all day and figure out they have
infinite number of tools to undermine
whatever you try to change whatever you
try to change they and one of their
usual tools is to to act like if you
want that disclosure or you're concerned
about that you know you ask any
questions about that they they try to
act like that means you're a sort of low
low-level risky borrower you know and of
course our high quality borrowers uh
wouldn't be worried about this
government regulation and they they can
just get people to ignore it so that
kind of um whether you come out in the
Willis side in her context she looks at
it closely and disclosure doesn't work
that's good to know as well uh but let's
look at specific contexts and gather
data so that we at least start answering
Amy's question and one of the places
that is most uh apt to be doing that
right now as a Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau which is very
dedicated to that question and I think
specifically to to answering some of
Professor Willis's questions so yeah and
well so there's uh I'm actually one of
the five people who's on the academic
Advisory Board of the consum final uh uh
Protection Bureau and uh that's it's
very true I mean uh I should be clear
that Willis's study uh does not mean
that all Consumer Finance disclosure is
not helpful but in the specific context
of larger dollar loans uh I think she
has a lot of good evidence there can I
make one quick comment the one one very
interesting issue that I think we could
be discussing is how much helpful
information we can provide to Consumers
and how much does that offset the bad
stuff that's going on and um so the kind
of studies that Christine was talking
about are highly appealing and it's
great to have scientific information out
there of that sort in fact we did a
series of studies kind of on that that
very topic of traffic light diets and
different things but one of the things
that always worried me about that isn't
whether we were going down a road where
we were going to create this much good
in the face of this much bad and we're
in and and if we go down that road of of
disclosure and providing warning labels
or whatever it happens to be it's good
no question I mean it's helpful probably
especially if we get it right if we get
the messages right but does it give
industry a free pass from doing the bad
things or does it forgive them from
doing the bad things and do we assume
that we could ever do enough of the
helpful things to offset what the
industry is doing and until the
government is saying we're going to
spend spend $100 million by January 4th
to help counteract all these terrible
messages let's say we we do get it right
we get the messages right I just don't
think we can ever compete on those
grounds and that's why it's really good
that we're going after these helpful
messages no question about it but I'm
just worried that it is just ignoring
the tidal wave of bad messages and we
really need to go after that in some
way I think there's also this additional
complicating factor of sort of the legal
tradition of difference to legislative
fact finding
and how you're going to get this
empirical evidence to legislators and
who's going to evaluate whether the
legislators did their research correctly
where they brought in all the legal
experts and how we're going to integrate
sort of uh politics into this empirical
Arena um so we start at five minutes
late so we're going to go just a few
minutes over so what I think we should
do if it's okay with you three is just
to collect your questions each of you
ask your questions and then we can open
it up to the panel to answer those
questions and offer some concluding
Reflections go ahead thank you I'm Peter
onlyy I'm professor of Public Health
Medicine University of St Andrews in
Scotland and I'm here as a guest of Dean
Paul clear uh thank you very much for
some fantastic presentations I want to
pick up on Nadia's point about Congress
members as irrational
actors I um I may have been spending too
much time in American hotel
rooms because I found myself the other
day watching C-SPAN
and it was a debate for an open senate
seat and it it is possible that the two
candidates actually believed in some of
the positions they were
articulating but you know they seem too
pretty smart folk and and so I really
don't think they
did I I think rather what they were
doing was they were speaking direct to
the people who were backing them
financially and there were certain
positions that they had to adopt if
their campaign War chest was to remain
intact for the duration of the campaign
so my question to any of the panel who
would like to take it on is to what
extent do you think one of the real
problems here is that democracy has been
for
sale and that actually the people who go
to Washington to run this country are
hindered in thinking and acting and
voting in the way that they would like
to do so because of their need to keep
funders on board thank you
Kristen thanks my question is primarily
for Nadia and Christine um I was really
struck by the fact that a lot of the
evidence that you cited Christin uh
focuses on responses to a a first
impression of seeing the ads or seeing
the picture Plus the message um and I'm
wondering if when we're designing
pictorial warnings or pictorial messages
if there's also if we can design those
better to account for the dynamism of
our emotions and our preferences and our
risk perceptions over time um and I was
thinking about whether it's possible
that people just become accustomed to
these images over time maybe they come
become less powerful U maybe they play
with our emotions less um and then I was
also curious about the potential for
warnings based my
um where for example because the fat
calories are broken out on the nutrition
label we pay a lot of attention to fat
but we don't really pay very much
attention to sugar and to the extent
that pictorial representations enhance
our kind of very specific focus on one
aspect of something um do we need to
think about that when we're designing
this and so I guess what I'm getting at
is are These Warnings always going to be
maybe playing a game of ketchup and can
we design those regulations with that in
mind so that they're they leave some
leeway for that adaptation thank last
one um my question is Al also for
Christine um I had a question about the
study comparing the pictorial and the
textual um the two groups that that
looked at uh the combination versus just
the text and um while in some cases they
were statistically significant I was
really surprised to find that the you
know um response rate the accuracy of
the responses were you know in one case
difference between 62% 64% I guess I
just expected a much greater jump and I
was just wondering in your test if there
were some kind of negative controls or
something where they showed the text
associated with an unrelated picture or
maybe a conflicting picture and also in
in those studies was there an age uh
relationship to uh to the response rate
thank you do each of you want to respond
or I I will uh just uh respond in a very
short statement given the time um and
offer to talk more tomorrow morning um
or uh later uh and actually I can I can
unify the last couple questions and um
Abby your comment uh I mean the these
questions were a a beautiful
instantiation of Amy's question about
you know how much empirical evidence
isn't yes it's very complicated um
agencies do an amazing job of I mean
they're not perfect by any means but I
have to say in the last couple years
doing this research and reading you know
the 300 pages from OSHA on their new
pictorial labels and how they try to
handle the empirical evidence and these
brilliant complexities that the last two
questioners raised it's far from a
perfect process but we have agencies and
experts to do that and I'm very
optimistic about it and I would love to
talk more about it tomorrow
morning concluding any responses uh just
briefly about money in in in politics
yes I live in Berkeley California H
where on the November ballot there is a
1 cent per ounce tax that could be
placed on sugar sweetened Beverages and
if it can't pass in Berkeley where in
the world or at least where in the
United States could it pass and it might
not so uh and that is not unrelated to
the fact that the pro uh tax side has
has spent $200,000 and the anti-tax has
uh just crossed the $2 million Mark
Nadia
I I don't know if uh if I have too much
to add yes democra democracy for sale I
also I sort of share the concern uh
about myopia in terms of disclosures we
pay attention to what is presented to us
and there may be other concerns that are
also important uh and that I think again
is up
to agencies to make good decisions about
not just what need not just how things
are disclosed but also what needs to be
disclosed so that we're
making sure that consumers have
important information across the
Spectrum and not just focusing on one
element K one of the things that we
didn't talk about but I think would be
very important too at some point is the
possibility of litigation in in this
context and are there parties out there
who could um go after advertisers let's
say or others for creating harm like the
Attorneys General did with um with
tobacco okay let's give a big Round of
Applause for trific
channel Amy do you have any
announcements that we need to make
before we adjourn or are we
adjourned we're adjourned
everybody nice
job